Und leute ich weiß montags 12.30 ist vielleicht nicht die beste zeit zum streben
Es gibt ja leute die müssen arbeiten habe ich gehört um die uhrzeit
Soll vereinzelt
Vorkommen
Ja leute ich weiß auch nicht so genau also es ist sehr merkwürdig
Aus irgendwelchen gründen habe ich bock weiter paar runden Battlefield zu spielen
Ich wollte eigentlich vorhin ein video aufnehmen
So mal allgemein so ihr wisst ja das letzte video zu battlefield 2042 und sowas ja
Wo ich mich mal drüber auslasse ob sich denn jetzt wirklich auch für die hardcore battlefield fans die es noch nicht gekauft haben sich vielleicht lohnt
Mal rein zu gucken ich denke übrigens dass ich das immer noch nicht lohnt
Es lohnt sich nur wenn man das vielleicht mal im sale kriegt und wirklich gar nichts anderes findet was
Was einen irgendwie happy macht so als
battlefield
Veteranen dann kann man sich mal gedanken drüber machen aber es ist deutlich näher an einem fertigen game mittlerweile dran als vorher aber zumindest
Ich wollte vorhin ein video aufnehmen und ich habe auch schon angefangen ein paar sätze dazu aufzuschreiben
Aber ich dachte so ich könnte ja eigentlich auch noch ein paar runden spielen im stream beziehungsweise ich habe mir gedacht ich könnte paar runden
noch spielen
Und wenn ich paar runden spiele kann ich auch streamern machen
Immerhin das spricht irgendwie für das game wenn man sich mal so überlegt
Also spricht auf jeden fall für das game wenn man sagt auch nach zweimal paar stunden man hat noch bock
auch mal einzuschalten und paar runden zu spielen
Aber nur rush ihr kennt mich rush only
Ich kann mir conquest und gerade gerade breakthrough kann ich mir in dem spiel nicht geben
Ich habe übrigens jetzt auch rausbekommen
warum
Ich so abgefuckt war mit assault rifles zu spielen
Die sind verpackt die sind nicht wie man in den patchnotes lesen kann einfach nur
Genervt worden was so den recoil und den den bullet spread angeht nein der reset vom bullet spread
Wenn du taps schießt ja dann sollte sich eigentlich deinen bullet spread reduzieren aber der reset nicht richtig
Deswegen habe ich auch gestern so oft einfach random durch leute durchgeschossen obwohl ich genau drauf gewesen bin
Ich bin gestern halb durchgedreht bei
Und das ist verpackt also mal wieder was neues am start wo da ist sich wo man sich so fragen muss ob da ist ihren kram
überhaupt ausprobiert im vorfeld
Ja anscheinend sind assault rifles nicht nur krass genervt sondern auch noch verpackt ist natürlich eine tolle kombination
Und ich habe übrigens nachgeschaut
Legacy passt doch das ist doch legacy feature field und container mit legacy features mit containern
Er hat vergessen was ich sagen wollte achso ja ich habe nachgeschaut
Es soll tatsächlich mit season 5 also mit der aktuellen season eine überarbeitung von hourglass kommen
hourglass ist ja die letzte also die eine der
miesesten maps überhaupt und eines der und die letzte map die überarbeitet wird
allerdings
Nicht direkt zum release von season 5 sondern soll im laufe im laufe von season 5
5 soll die überarbeitung von hourglass kommen das heißt dann hat man ernsthaft
Ihr müsst euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen lasst ich mal die nächste season kommt ja irgendwie wieder september oktober oder so was da muss
man sich mal überlegen dann haben die zwei jahre nach release gebraucht die eh schon nicht vielen maps in diesem spiel
so zu überarbeiten
dass sie
Annehmbar spielbar sind ich würde noch nicht mal so weit gehen und sagen die sind so nicht gut spielbar
Weil machen wir mal kurz battlefield 2042 mal kurz so eine kleine
map tierlist
ok also
Kann man das vielleicht auch auf englisch stellen die seite dass ich irgendwie die map
einfach nur jen
Shit man warum ist es warum hat es kein sprach warum hat es kein sprach slider
Wo kann ich die langweilig umstellen ah ja
Ja
Kona also was haben wir was haben wir für maps machen wir mal kurz so kleine
map tierlist flashpoint kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern
Was war flashpoint?
ah die im gebirge
die die die mit dem ja von von der von der season davor
Ist schon schlimm wenn du noch nicht mal anhand des maps weißt welche maps eigentlich ist
Ja das ist die mit dem gebirge die so ein bisschen an in rush so ein bisschen an die
zweiten base so ein bisschen an dem moment peak erinnert
So vom vom gebirge her und der und dem map layout ja okay flashpoint
die ist okay
spearhead die ist in rush auch ganz okay
stranded
Die ist auch ganz okay also die neuen maps sind tatsächlich in ordnung exposure
Exposure muss ich tatsächlich sagen finde ich recht pepega in rush
Ich habe es nicht oft gespielt mit den neuen mit dem neuen mcom placement vielleicht ist es jetzt besser
Aber die letzte version fand ich nicht sonderlich
gut spielbar in rush hourglass die schlechteste map ever
Also wenn es wenn es sowas wie z tier geben würde dann käme hourglass da rein
hourglass ist übrigens auch diese famous map wo damals
shroud war das glaube ich
wo shroud battlefield gespielt hat nach release und dann mit dem jet in so in so ein hochhaus geflogen ist und abgeprallt ist und
nicht nicht zerstört wurde
Der clip erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer dran der clip hat er ein bisschen die runde gemacht
Also hourglass ist wirklich z tier schlechter geht es nicht und ich lehne mich mal aus dem fenster ich sag sogar in allen spielmodi
conquest weiß ich nicht genau ich spiele sehr wenig conquest das wisst ihr breakthrough für nasch und
rush auch für nasch
hourglass sagt
so discarded
nicht ganz so schlimm wie hourglass
Und auch mit der überarbeitung ich muss ehrlich sagen ich mag die map nicht finde hourglass
discarded ist auch
Müll manifest finde ich fast mit die beste map die im release des games drin war
Ich finde die spielt sich ganz gut
das neue mcom placement in rush gefällt mir aber nicht weil
Ich finde es war erst gar nicht mal nötig da so viel dran zu ändern
Die erste map in die ersten mcoms in den containern waren ppiger ja aber das war aber rush hatte auf manifest einen schönen verlauf
Von der küste auf den berg hoch und jetzt ist es sehr inspiriert einfach erste base kisten zweite base kisten dritte base kisten
Okay dritte base ist glaube ich tankstelle aber das ist langweilig trotzdem manifest manifest ist ganz in ordnung
kaleidoskop
rots map in rush
orbital
anfangen müll danach
okay
Und die raketenbasis beziehungsweise hier diese was ist das raketenbass ja das hier die diese die diese base hier der selbe die raketen
Die ist in rush auch ein bisschen doof aber das geht noch das ist so mittleres tier so c tier oder so würde ich sagen
Breakaway
Eigentlich auch müll
Renewal geht so mal gute runden mal schlechte runden geht so
Okay, bleiben wir bleiben wir mal dabei eigentlich die hälfte der maps
schrott
Okay sind wir mal fair ein drittel der maps immer noch schrott
Ein weiteres drittel der maps spielbar und ein weiteres drittel der maps ganz okay
So so ungefähr würde ich sagen wir wie gesagt auf rush bezogen es ist natürlich meine meinung
Letztendlich hat jeder so ein eigenes ein bisschen eigenen geschmack was maps angeht ich glaube ich glaube wir können uns alle darauf einigen
Dass our class einfach schrott ist in jedem spielmodus und ich frage mich ernsthaft ob die überarbeitung von our class
Was bringt weil es hat sicherlich seinen sinn dass die überarbeitung von our class bis jetzt aufgeschoben wurde die wissen einfach nicht was
Sie mit der map machen sollen was was willst du mit dieser schrott map eigentlich noch wie was wirst du damit machen
Ich wüsste nicht wie man die recyceln kann außer einfach noch mehr kisten an alle stellen stellen was sie machen werden
Bisher sahen ja map überarbeitung so aus einfach überall kisten hinstellen
Montag ist immer frei montags richtig ja deswegen bin ich jetzt ja auch on wie gesagt die zeit ist äußerst unglücklich
Was man auch sieht es sind gerade 85 ganze 85 leute im stream
Ist halt auch eine blöde ist schön dass ihr übrigens alle da seid die da sind
Ist natürlich eine blöde zeit die meisten leute müssen jetzt arbeiten
Und wohingegen irgendwelche it bustle streams man seinem chef vielleicht noch als weiterbildung verkaufen könnte wird es bei einem battlefield
2042 stream natürlich ein bisschen gerät man vielleicht ein bisschen in erklärungsnot
So ich werfe das game mal an übrigens wenn ihr euch fragt
Arbeiten richtig cringe
Wer macht denn sowas also wirklich cringe wer noch arbeiten muss
Ihr macht das game mal an mal gucken übrigens für alle die sich fragen
Weil ich sag das jetzt weil das die letzten zwei streams öfters mal aufgekommen ist
Weil er die sich fragen lohnt es sich jetzt rein zu gucken also
Einfache antwort ist wenn ihr das game schon habt auf jeden fall es gab eine neue season es gab auch ganz viele sachen die ich
cool finde wobei cool in anführungsstrichen halt mit ihren
Möglichkeiten die sie haben
Jetzt bleibt immer noch ein battlefield light aber ein paar ganz coole sachen dabei
Auch die attachments für world weapons und sowas eigentlich ganz gut also wenn ihr geld schon für das game ausgegeben habt dann auf jeden fall
Denn aktuell sind die spielerzahlen halt auch ganz gut
Wenn das ist klar also aktuell sind die spielerzahlen auch ganz ganz brauchbar
an sich ist halt
Immer noch ein witz aber es ist schon ganz okay
Aktuell also wenn ihr schon geld dafür ausgegeben habt dann macht das wenn ihr euch fragt
Oder denkt alter ich hätte mal richtig bock wieder auf eine runde battlefield und lohnt sich das zu kaufen
Dann würde ich sagen es lohnt sich zum normalen preis nicht zu kaufen
Aber ihr könnt mal drüber nachdenken wenn das irgendwie reduziert ist so für 20 euro oder so kann man sich das mal geben
Okay wir machen mal
Warum wollen die mir eigentlich allen ernstes madden nfl 24 ist nfl
Das ist doch football oder ist nf ich dachte immer nfl ist eishockey nee aber das ist football
Was ist an die nhl ist ist eishockey alle die amis mit ihren liegen das blickt doch kein mensch durch
Und davon abgesehen interessiert mich auch absolut gar nicht so null
Ich meine mich interessiert quasi eh schon keine sportart so wirklich dass ich die verfolgen würde
Also klassische sportart die ein oder anderen e-sport tournaments gucke ich tatsächlich wobei es die letzten letzten
Letzten 1 2 jahre tatsächlich sehr sehr wenig geworden ist was ich e-sport gucke also overwatch ist ja eh komplett für mich gestorben war
Ja, ich schon nicht weil ich schon nicht nicht schaubar eine ganze weile
Es gab eine zeit da habe ich sehr viel cs geguckt mache ich auch kaum noch
Das letzte größere e-sport turnier was ich geguckt habe war glaube ich das letzte
Wie heißt das international dota 2 wo ich einige games geguckt habe
Und das muss ich sagen als jemand der dota nicht spielt ich finde die veranstaltung einfach gut gemacht
Was was bei dem was bei dem diesjährigen
Dota turnier wohl irgendwie die leute ein bisschen verwirrt hatte
Weiß nicht ob ihr das ob ihr das mitbekommen habt
Sie hatten irgendwie so eine porno darstellerin als moderatorin oder als als reporterin oder als
Spieler interviewerin oder so was es ist irgend so eine webcam porno darstellerin rumgerannt
Das habe ich auch aus dem nachhinein irgendwo gelesen okay, naja warum nicht ja
Aber das turnier das turnier ist wirklich super organisiert gewesen kann sich sagen also man merkt schon
Dass das auf einem anderen level ist wie so ein crap wie overwatch league oder so was
Ja ich weiß nicht warum was sie sich dabei gedacht haben aber anscheinend haben sie das für einen guten move gehalten warum auch nicht ja
Buber
Okay auf geht's vielleicht soll ich mal die musik ausmachen mal schauen ob windows
Wie sieht eigentlich mein battle pass aus bin ich jetzt eigentlich 23 nee was fehlt mir noch free
Auf was bezieht sich denn das free hier unten
Das UI ist so pp gar ich weiß überhaupt nicht was die wollen von mir
Ach das kriege ich nur mit dem premium battle pass ach so nö nö könnt ihr mal einfach knicken
Von mir kriegt ihr kein geld mehr ich habe mir den jahrespass gekauft
Allein schon für den vorgabe ist für den für den vertrauensvorschuss sollte dem ja eigentlich bis zu meiner rechnung
Eigentlich bis zu meiner rente premium in dem game geben aber nee
Ich warte ja noch auf level
Also ich hoffe ich habe genug motivation akuma skip missions er braucht so was
Ich hoffe ja noch dass ich die g36 sorry sorry nicht die g36
Waffen namen rechte kaufen ist ja outdated ich meine natürlich die
Keck w 46
Aber es ist eindeutig die g36
Ist es nicht in warzone 2 und generell in den letzten call of duty teilen auch so exposure nicht auch so gewesen
Dass sie die waffen namen so ganz merkwürdig gemacht haben so so wie hieß wie hieß die mp5 jetzt in
Ausschnitt wir sind der hat geholfen sind wir attacker wir sind attacker
Was anderes kommt mal das ding da hätte ich mal wieder bock drauf ist es ist es wie
lachmann hieß das ding doch oder in
Nicht kein sein wenn es darauf lachmann
Ist das ding doch in mb2
Oh Mist irgendwie habe ich gedacht das geht nach
Ja lachmann
Das ist auch so ein ding ich ich teilweise erkenne ich diese dinger gar nicht richtig die die eigenen teammate marker
Weil die weil die oftmals so in den hintergrund geraten
Wait a minute wissen wir sind der ticke nee ich wollte gerade sagen das ticket anzeige ist komisch an der stelle
Was werde ich hier einfach geschneidt
Anzeige
Okay, leute erste runde
Präpariert mal für ppg am
Wie ei moment wir spielen
Wir spielen gegen ei
Wir haben gegen wichs gegen wen haben wir gerade gekillt wie wichsos weifu
Die leute haben wieder namen heute waren
Was für ein dämlicher namen
Pass auf den den den facen wir jetzt und bashen den
Da ist er wieder wichsos weifu
Gebashed haben wir nicht ganz sicher wo die hin sind
Oh shit veraimt ich sagte richtig richtig massive ppg
So geht es mir die ersten paar runden immer und den restlichen stream auch aber die ersten paar runden ist immer schlimm
Oh Mist ich dachte wir haben es schon fast
Okay
Ich dachte ich komme vielleicht noch irgendwie durch aber da sind teammates da können wir uns spawnen
Okay ich gehe ich gehe lieber bei dem rein
Wie viel tickets haben wir noch 60 okay das sieht ganz brauchbar aus
Shit das wird schwierig hier rüber zu kommen hier pass mal auf yolo
Okay, nice
Da ist schon einer auf dem dach
Da kann da ist er schon wieder ach nee wichsos warflos ich habe irgendwie aus irgendwelchen gründen weifu gelesen
Da ist er wie schnell spawnt der kerl eigentlich kann mir das mal einer erklären
Okay jetzt aber lege henne
Pass auf da kommen gleich noch mehr
Ich kämpfe ich kämpfe mir jetzt hier einen ab
pass mal auf
Ja ja ja ja
Jetzt jetzt aber die haben es ernsthaft noch diffuse geht
Alter was war denn das
Was sagst du dazu starfield ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was da fehlt genau war
Okay, wenn du jetzt sagst ein game dann ja ja das ist mir auch klar
Aber fällt mir jetzt gar nicht ein welches
Okay unten ist richtig was los leute
smoke
Okay schlechte schlechte smoke posi
Okay, der wird geschotten
Pack man immer in battlefield der den du nicht siehst man immer den du nicht siehst
Shit da sind schon wieder welche
Okay, ich sollte ich sollte schnell respawn weil ich glaube nicht dass ich dass ich den rats krieg das neue betreffende pg. Ach das
Ja ja das hat mich nicht so geschockt
Okay, jetzt sollten wir es haben ich glaube wir haben es
Jawohl
Aber können die mal sterben? Nö, haben keinen bock
Haben sie keinen Bock, no pass, gestorben wird hier nicht auf dem dach ist einer
Ist das seriously in dem moment wo ich aufs dach hoch bin vom dach runter gesprungen ja sehe ich das richtig
Bräuchte man so eine smoke granate um das auszumachen ist das noch gefährlich jetzt
Bin mir unschlüssig wo die letzte base ist war die und das ist die base die unten im tal ist
Da konnte man doch von oben runterjumpen
Das probieren wir mal aus das habe ich das habe ich lange nicht mehr gespielt rush letzte base hier exposure mal gucken
Hier ging es schon mal nett runter
Der hat mir aber ein pick of wish bestellt
Ich kann sehr leise, ach ne das ist schon alles unten oder
Ne finde ich gar nicht das ist das ist eines der der eigenständigsten map die dieses spiel hat
Game hallo player in parachute ja das hätte ich auch sagen
Alter wie das wackelt
Okay, wir müssen auf jeden fall hier lang nicht da unten
Der rest sagt hier müssen wir lang
Jawohl hier ist gut
Mal kurz heilen
Da sitzt er in der ecke
Da sitzt er in der ecke dachte ich würde gerne nachladen
Die legehenne ist am start b okay niemand auf b
Bin mir nicht sicher ist nach ist nach der runde ist hier vorbei jetzt
Bam ja easy
Zwar nicht wirklich objektiv aber zumindest
Ordentlich was gekillt die runde
Most wie der hat mehr kills. Ah, was das hätte ich noch mal ein zwei mehr gekillt
Next so jetzt gucken wir mal kurz auf die uhr. Ach, es gibt ja keine sekunden mehr in der windows uhr. Ich habe vergessen
Das ist so schlecht ich wollte eigentlich jetzt ja
Es gibt halt keine sekunden mehr in der uhr
Okay 13 uhr 4 ich wollte gucken wie lang also 13 ziemlich genau 13 uhr 4 war das
Ich wollte gucken wie lang es dauert bis die nächste runde wirklich startet
Also gefühlt dauert das viel viel viel zu lang
Ja, ich weiß es gibt zig uhren online, aber warum gibt es keine sekundenanzeige mehr in der windows uhr
Das ist das ist auch legacy features
das letzte windows 11 feature
beste map ever
Da habe ich darauf gewartet dass ich jetzt hourglass spielen darf
Das ging erstaunlich schnell moment. Es geht noch nicht los. Es geht noch nicht los
Wir sind noch nicht gespawnt. Ich mag sekunden wenn ich wissen will wie viel zeit vergangen ist. Ja
Da sind also wenn man wissen will wie viel zeit vergangen ist genau dann sind sekunden schon sehr praktisch
Okay, jetzt geht's los
Eineinhalb minuten und das ging schnell das matchmaking war instant diesmal
Eineinhalb minuten eigentlich zwei weil ich habe erst nach dem outro geguckt eigentlich zwei minuten
Zwei minuten zwischen den runden
von also bevor man
Die kontrolle weg hat über den player über die über die spielfigur. Oh, Mist was habe ich hier ordentliche attachments dran machen man
Wir spielen die beste map im spiel leute
Beste map im game
Gibt keine bessere. Ich hoffe die ich hoffe die wird nicht überarbeitet weil du kannst perfektion nicht überarbeiten
Richtige banger map. Ja
Mal gucken vielleicht gucken sie jetzt richtung a und nicht so sehr ob ich hier flank action mache über b
Okay, wir sind wir sind wohl schon dran
Wir sind wohl schon dran
So ich meine ich soll mir mal
Da jetzt aber gut hier lasst mich doch mal in ruhe
Okay, muss ja doch rüber vielleicht
Der spread reset mit tap mit burst nicht das verpackt
Okay, wenn wir glück haben
Einfach fünf gegner vor mir da machst du nix die sind wirklich genau gleichzeitig aufgeploppt schnell
respond
Respond heimer ist übrigens auch outdated overrated sie betet das braucht man anscheinend nicht
Damage also das ist so fehl mit den assault rifles hast du nicht mal gescheit schießen kannst
Ihr habt es gesehen die hälfte der börse ist einfach komplett durchgeflogen
Oh, ja ist
Keine ahnung, wo er ist ich kämpfe jetzt unter der treppe
blöd richtig blöd in die einheit zu gehen in dem moment
Was ist mit dem los?
14 kill
Ja krasser schneider dude
charlie mike
Seid ihr auch charlie mike
charlie mike leute
Ich auch, aber ich habe meine klimaanlage an da muss man nicht derz sein
Best ich hoffe die wer die map wird nie angepasst ist einfach so geil hier so über das offene feld ist einfach das geilste
zum glück treffen die nix
Die deckung ist einfach poggers
einfach komplett poggers
zum glück hat es sich nicht bewegt
Oh pants pants man
Lass mich in ruhe panzer
Du bist traurig dass die vergessen dass die dass die zwei jahre zum anpassen der map gebraucht haben verstehe ich gar nicht
Es ist einfach perfektion
Ich meine was willst du hier anpassen
Nichts angepasst ist immer noch nichts
Okay, ich meine ich habe
Ich habe einen smoke launcher dabei den benutzen wir jetzt mal passt mal auf massive smoke
Poggers smoke
Aber das war es schon das reicht mir nicht das ist zu wenig ich komm ich komm nicht
Direkt vor lasst mich in ruhe lasst
Ich habe es geschafft leute easy easy
Ich meine
das ist halt nichts in der nähe
Alter ich bin der einzige da hier liegen guckt ihr das so an
Okay weiter weiter weiter
Okay wir gehen das ein bisschen links
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären warum das am anfang nicht nicht gekillt hat ihn
Warum hat er das am anfang nicht gekillt lasst mich spawnen game ich will auf den klicken
Smoke smoke wir sind so o.p. smoke
Jawohl
wir sind was
Was ist mit denen los machen machen die punkte booster
Wussten die sich haben die sich gerade punkte geboostet
Oder was war das geht das kann gibt es irgend so ein rechts ist ein panzer
Jetzt kommt der sandsturm ich bin froh dass dieses game kaum noch wetter effekte hat
Zwei das ist einfach viel zu viel zu pp gar gewesen
Ich meine das ist okay
ab und zu mal
So wir haben eine granate da rein
Okay okay nice geben
Welche ist näher b okay lege henne
Lege henne
Du du du du du du du du du du da ist kommen die ersten granaten reingeflogen
Okay ich kämpfe ich kämpfe mal hier eine runde
Okay, fass mal auf. Oh shit schlechte idee mal. Oh, oh panzer
Shit
Aber wir haben es wir haben es nice wir haben es wir haben es das war ganz schön klaus
Nice wir haben es easy
Okay, dass das war einfacher als gedacht
Und unser sniper dude geht ja da ab vorne 22
Das ist da gar nicht mehr
Was ist mit den assault rifles los man
Ich glaube ich musste lmg spielen
Das geht ja gar nicht zurzeit das fliegt ja alles durch
Die leben doch bestimmt noch hier oder leben hier noch ein paar
Legt das am magazin nee reload speed reload speed ist kein ding
Dass das burst nicht funktioniert ja ich habe das heute morgen in einem video gesehen
Ich bin gestern halb verzweifelt und heute auch weil der burst also die ist der weapon spread resettet sich nicht richtig
Das ist richtig mies da kannst du eigentlich nur eher 68 oder wie dieses ding heißt spielen weil das ding weil das ding an sich schon
so op ist
okay smoke
lege henne
jawohl
Ich würde gerne das squad wechseln mit leuten die vielleicht irgendwie vorne sind bei den gegnern
Spawn spawn ist dead
Wie viel fps
Perf overlay draw fps ups 1
330 340 oder so was das ist aber auch nicht höchste grafikqualität muss ich gleich dazu sagen
Sag mal die assault rifles ist doch echt hängen geblieben gerade
Der hat natürlich auch seine seine haken geschlagen wollten nicht getroffen zu werden aber der sind wieder einfach sachen straight durchgeflogen
Ja ich glaube bleibt er m 58
Guckt sich das an
Ich habe nix wq hd nix wq hd
Okay, leute ich muss was anderes streicht kräftetrainer im durchbrei
Scheiß drauf ist das map bleiben wir einfach hier drin ist doch egal sagten wir halt auch mal eine runde lang
Nein game ich will da nicht hoch ich wollte unten rein
Okay wenn da jetzt einer rankommt von euch dann ist der der tge
Natürlich das ist durch ich ich muss echt was anderes spielen die assault rifles sind so pp gar gerade
Ich mach den sound voll gut
Vielleicht sollten sie mich engagieren als nächstes fürs nächste battlefield aber ein paar sound effekte
Bei der way das ist das hier war eigentlich eines meiner lieblings
Das hat nicht so schnell geschossen
Aber das war relativ genau also war
Ich glaube wir sollten mal ein paar lmgs anlocken
Lmg legit
Panzer oben am start
Okay
Wie kommt wie kommt man da jetzt am besten rauf
Also ich glaube wir sollten mal ein paar lmgs anlocken
Okay
Wie kommt wie kommt man da jetzt am besten rauf ich sehe die gar nicht weiß gar nicht wo die sind
Ich sehe noch nicht mal die
Exzellent
Oh
Alter was ist was geht mir denn
Sekunde sekunde wir müssen jetzt mal kurz die waffe switchen
Das ist mal nix nehmen wir mal das teil
Nice sehr gut endlich mal einer der direktrichtung objektiv ist so mal gucken ob wir uns unseren
Unseren grappling hook ein bisschen ausspielen können
580 gegner
Man muss nicht mehr hoch aufs hochhaus das ist schon mal eine gute neuerung das war ja komplett hängen geblieben
Gibt es irgendwelche gerüchte
Nee
Fallen mir keine ein jetzt
Ganz ehrlich ich glaube auch nicht dass noch vieles an maps geben wird es wird noch mal eine season 6 geben und wahrscheinlich also mit
Mit diesen sechs müsste es ja dann theoretisch
Theoretisch müsste es mit diesen sechs ja
zwei neue maps geben
Weil die überarbeitung der maps sind ja mit diesen fünf abgeschlossen das glaube ich aber nicht
Kommt mal wir haben 500 fps
Battlepass level 18 mit wann mit wann kam die kekwe 36 kekwe 46 27
Ja das dauert noch ein bisschen
Wir haben komisches komisches zeug anlockt was ich eh nicht brauche
Was könnte man denn mal spielen wenn assault rifles irgendwie satten
lmgs habe ich nicht ich habe null lmgs gespielt guck mal doch die anscheinend ein bisschen
Ich habe wirklich ich habe so gut wie nichts an lmgs gespielt was ist eine gute lmg
haben wir denn hier
Weil paraiso
Hawk map
ACWR das ist doch ein assault rifle das ist doch kein
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren ob die taugt
ACWR ist momentan wahrscheinlich beste assault rifle
Chat wenn ihr sagt ich habe jetzt schon verschiedenste sachen gehört einer meinte
rm rm 86 68 wäre die beste gestern ein neues meta mta 21 dann kam der nächste an mit
IK neues der
Aber endlich mal eine neue map
Bad company 2 wird ja ende des jahres abgestellt wobei das weiterhin weiter laufen wird kann ja jetzt schon sagen man
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine scar oder
Kriegt man auch noch ein bisschen größere magazine
Okay, ich mache meine bad company 2 route in der hoffnung mich kämmt keiner ab
Ich habe keinen silencer und nix
game
Shit ich dachte der erste ist der ich kann um umzielen auf den zweiten
Knapp hätte was werden können hätte ich die zwei erwischt wo ist der rest
no rpg und infnoob
direkt gebannt vom server
Wow da ist ganz schön was los
Monka
Ich liege da ich liege da etwas exposed gerade
Nicer dachstelz btw das spotten funst nicht richtig
Das spotten ich habe die 500 mal versucht zu spotten schon aber es war
Von der seite schneiden wir sollten es haben denke ich haben wir es jawohl
Next warum bleibt das spawn hier hinten und geht nicht vor zur nächsten base
Ich muss gerade mal was ausprobieren geht okay nein muss ich nicht ausprobieren
Ich
Wollte gucken ob das auf diesen berg klitschen hier noch geht das war ja in bc2 so eine so eine richtige abfahrt position
Wo hier oben haben die schneider die schneider dudes immer gehockt ja das gibt es immer noch
Die ganzen die ganzen schneider leute die die ganze runde hier oben rum gekämpft haben
Wo geht da was
Ich brauche smoke ich brauche mal ein smoke auf der auf der
smoke auf der auf der straße
noch ein smoke
die seite noch zu smoken
Okay nice jetzt rein hier gib ihm wir machen flank action flank flank pockers flank
Habe ich noch einen schuss
Gibt es nicht konnte man nicht wie hat was mit dem los wie trotze wie
wie trotzt man noch mal diesen komischen hund
jemanden plan
Wie ging das noch mal b
Was jetzt ist die runde vorbei
Aber das leute ich sage euch wie es ist die battlefield 3 soldaten voice lines waren immer noch immer noch die besten
da ist doch einer drin hier
Okay yolo style
Ja
Ich liebe uns
Ich liebe mich
Ja gut das war gut das warn exkelenter exquisite. Hi understsand. Nein nicht sterben leute
Nein, nein, nicht sterben dich der las mich spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn spawn
Quadge
Aber wir haben es, nice
Gib Gas, Alda
Ja Leute
Ja das ist echt gewöhnungsbedürftig mit den Assault Rifles
jetzt zu schießen
Oh da unten ist was
Ne
Das war nur so ne komische Sentry Gun
Wer kann die Sentry Gun nochmal setzen, Boris?
Ne, Irish, gell?
Ne, ne, Moment
Keine Ahnung
Boris
Da ist ne Claymore drinnen
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Da war ne Claymore drinnen
Direkt
Ist halt geil, dass du in BC2 noch durch Holzbretter
durchschießen kannst, aber
im geilen
neuesten Battlefield
von 2021
da
geht das natürlich
nicht
Gameplay Pog, freut mich, dass es euch gefällt
Da freut man sich
als 39 jähriger, fast 39 jähriger
Boomer natürlich drüber
Shit, ich wollte mit der Shotgun
da rein
Richtig, richtig Hardcore Boomer
Ich wurde übrigens letztens
belehrt unter nem Youtube Video
Max, du verwendest das Wort Boomer falsch
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Und da hat er recht
Aber der hat halt noch nie
Boomer im Internet
Zusammenhang verwendet
Alter
Schaffst du noch die Nuke in
Modern Warfare, du meinst die im Originalen
Ja, Nuke im originalen
MW2 ist einfach
Chat, was für Killstreaks?
Nehmt ihr da immer so?
Ah, Shit, Alter, jetzt geht's aber wirklich
vorwärts gerade
Harrier, Chopper, Gunner, Nuke
Oder AC1 Third
Jetzt wird's schwierig
um hier durchzukommen
Okay, nice, jetzt ran hier
Gib dem
Meine Smoke
hat einfach nicht funktioniert
Wir haben's, nice
Safe
Shit, ich dachte, das wird vielleicht was
Hätte ja klappen können
Oh, Shit, wir brauchen B noch
Das wird nix
Das wird doch nix, oder?
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Oh, oh
Okay, wir wissen, Holz ist
Holz ist komplett
kugeldicht hier
Die können nicht durchs Holz schießen
Es ist aber ne harte
Runde gerade, Shit
Das wird nix
Es ist ne harte Runde
Oh, Pog
Lege Henne am Start
Lege Henne
Ganz schlechte Idee
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Oh, der macht Diffuske, Diffuske
Scheiße
Äh, ich kann nix machen
Ah, wie kommt man hier raus?
Wie kommt man hier raus?
Waren hier nicht immer so Sachen
wo man hoch konnte normalerweise?
Game, du
verpacktes Kackgame
Alter, okay, hier bin ich safe
Wenn, das kann man ja nicht
Oh, Shit
Shit
Ich bilde mir ein in Bad Company 2
Ich kann nicht drunter stehen, oder?
Wenn die jetzt nochmal Diffuske machen, raste ich aus
Ne, machen sie nicht
Das ist ein hartes Game gerade
Es ist wirklich ein hartes Game
Zumal man hier auch im Vergleich
Also Bad Company 2 war op
Da konntest du durch alles
durchschießen, ja
Aber das hier ist, guck mal
Du kannst nicht mal durch dieses fucking Holzding durchballern
Wow
Okay, jetzt
Jetzt müssen wir mal unsere
Unsere
BC2 Skills ausspielen gleich
Wenn man da oben, wenn man da hochkommt
Okay, Achtung, Achtung
Pass mal auf
BC2 Skill
Oh, Shit
Schlechte Idee, Max
Nix wie hoch wieder, ja
Oh, ey, ey, ey
Okay
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Na gut, man muss es
Man muss es probieren
Normal ist ja hier kein Durchkommen gescheit
ACR fühlt sich gut an, Leute
Oh, Shit
Was ist hier neben mir?
Was ist mit den PP-Gas hier los?
Nice
Also ACR fühlt sich wirklich ganz gut an
Leute, ihr habt recht gehabt
War eine gute Idee
Die ACR auszupacken
Wie sieht es mit B aus?
Ah, nice, A ist gleich down
Und B ist schon down
Pogu
Au
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen
Es sind ganz schön viele Gegner
3D-Spotting ist teilweise schon echt
eine PP-Gas-Sache
Ich mein, seriously, ich hab den Typ nicht gesehen
Ich hab den nicht gesehen
Ich hab einfach nur auf den Punkt geschossen
Okay, wir sind wieder Charlie Mike
3D-Spotting, lol
Okay, den können wir retzen
Oh
Der ist in der Sonne
Kann man joinen?
Das ist Matchmaking-Server
Kannst du mal
das Matchmaking
Das ist kein spezieller Server
Die Map ist mittlerweile in der normalen
Rotation drin
Okay, smoke
Oh
So, ich smoke die mal ein, die Dudes da hinten
So
Was denkt ihr euch so?
Ah, nice, hier kann man durchgletschen
Pog, das begrüße ich
Durch Felsen gucken
ist immer Pog
Okay, ich verpiss mich mal
Oh shit, ziemlich exposed
und wir haben keinerlei Smoke mehr
Äh, ich weiß nicht von wo
Keine Ahnung
Absolut nicht nachvollziehbar
für mich, wo grad was geht
Spielst du noch mal Konsole oder PC? PC
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben
So, hier, einmal Smoke fressen
Please
So, hier einmal Smoke fressen, please
Und hier
ihr auch nochmal Smoke, alle gut, alle wegsmoken
Shit
Zu viel
Also, ehrlich gesagt, ich finde
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Das bin ich sehend
Ah, ein kaputter Baum, okay
Ähm, ich finde, dass sowohl DICE
als auch EA man da blamen sollte
Für den
Fail bei diesem Game
Ich mein, EA hat irgendwelche komischen
Management-Geschichten gemacht, ja
Zu viel, zu viel auf einmal
Das kann ich nicht mal
Ähm, aber DICE hat es ja immerhin
So halt, wie nennt man das?
Gepitcht oder, äh, ja
Ausgearbeitet
Das wird schwierig, das wird wahrscheinlich nix
Hier reinzukommen noch mit den Tickets
Wir sind nicht in der Base
Wir haben, äh, keine Gegner
Keine Teammates irgendwie in der Nähe
Beide M-Comps sind noch da, ich glaube
Ich glaub, das wird nix
Alter, hier ist zu viel
Da machst du echt nix
Ich, ich mein
Ich probier es, ich probier es irgendwie durchzukommen
Aber es, es sieht nicht so aus
Als wird das was
Als ist es uns vergönnt
Hier die Runde zu gewinnen
Okay, volle Pulle rein hier
Geb ihm
Shit, alter
Drei Stück in diesem fucking Container
Krieg ich, krieg ich
Okay, vielleicht
Der sitzt, der sitzt halt
Nee, nee, nee, das wird nix
Das wird nix
Tickets müssten auch jetzt vorbei sein
Ja, zwölf Tickets
Hier oben haben wir noch zwei Leute
Das Einzige was wir machen können, noch mal ein bisschen
Den kann ich retzen
Aber das war es dann auch
Was ich machen kann
Ich kann einmal noch nachladen
Oh, das war es jetzt
Keine Chance
Du musst hier wirklich auf fünf
Fünf Fronten gleichzeitig gucken
Und das geht nicht, nope, keine Chance
Aber ein Kill vielleicht noch
Dass wir 40 haben
Einer noch
Nee, alle dead
Letztes Ticket
GG
Eats
Immer Eats, Leute
Je schwieriger die Runde, umso easier
Ihr kennt's
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz Chat lesen
Also erst mal mich meinen Statistiken erfreuen
Career best
Ja, mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Rifle
Okay
Chat gibt
Was gibt's hier?
Ja, die haben viel Blödsinn erzählt
Also auf was sich das bezogen hat
Ja, ich glaub das
Natürlich war das auf Portal gemeint, ja
Aber Portal ist halt im Endeffekt
Auch links liegen lassen worden
Also so richtig, so richtig
Love letter to the fans
Ich weiß ja nicht
Das ganze Ding ist halt sehr halbherzig
Ich frag mich immer noch, was haben die eigentlich mit den
Mit den hunderten Leuten gemacht
Die ganzen Jahre
Die an dem Game gearbeitet haben
Die haben ja erzählt, dass zwischenzeitlich 700
Das ist kein Spaß, Leute
Bis zwischenzeitlich 700 Leute
An dem Spiel gearbeitet haben
Und sie hatten ein eigenes Team, was sich nur um Fahrzeuge
Und Fahrzeugphysik und alles gekümmert hat
Und am Ende
Gab's halt zu Release irgendwie
Drei verschiedene Fahrzeuge, die sich alle kacke gesteuert haben
Lul
Was haben wir denn da?
Ey, was ist das?
Hä?
Hab ich das nicht schon?
Okay, Collection, ACR
Ah
Was ist denn da von die ACR hier?
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
36 Schuss
Das war mal hier vorne rein, 36 Schuss
Ah, das Ding
Schalldämpfer, 40 Meter
40 Meter
Ja, vielleicht
Ja, okay, in den zwei
Beport werd ich ja bestimmt nicht dran machen
Und Flashlight auch nicht
Orbital
Hoffentlich diesmal Attacker
Gestern war fast nur Defense
Und Defense ist halt gräudig
Auf der Map
Vielleicht
Ne, Accuracy while Static
Will ich auch nicht haben
Was ist denn das?
Lasersight
Quatsch, braucht auch keiner
Alles Blödsinn, brauchen wir nicht
Wir bleiben bei der nackischen
Oder bei der fast nackischen ACR
Ja
Ja, haben sie auch
Also es gibt ja immer noch
Also es gab ja dieses Gerücht, dass das eigentlich
Als Battle Royale, beziehungsweise später
Als Extraction Game geplant war
Und ich muss sagen, ich glaube das auch bis heute
Weil, oh Mist, ah ja
Team Switchen gibt es ja auch nicht
Weil, ich finde das ist der einzige Kontext
Wo das mit den Specialists
Irgendwie Sinn macht
So in diesem normalen Modus, sei es jetzt
Conquest oder sonst was, da haben die Specialists
Nie richtig reingepasst
Ja genau, dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, oh fuck wir haben ja
Apex
Okay
Ich war zu langsam, man muss bei Orbital
Direkt hier oben hin
Wenn man nicht gleich hier oben steht, bevor die Defender
Da hochkommt, hat man meistens
Die erste Base direkt verloren
Oh man, Game
Hör auf rumzuklitschen
Hab ich verkackt, ich hab geschossen
Obwohl ich nicht hätte schießen sollen, da wusste er, dass ich da war
Aber das muss man hier oben defenden
Dann hat man ne Chance
Wo ist denn der Typ
Mann
Spiel
Shit
Es waren zu viele
Es waren gerade 5 Leute oder so
Den hätte ich schon mit der Shotgun auf der Range
Direkt in den Kopf treffen müssen, dass das hingehauen hätte
Wow
Wie viele
Das war das halbe Team
Jetzt wollten sie es aber missen
Shit
Jetzt haben wir es eigentlich verloren
Okay
Game, hör doch mal auf
Mit dem rumgebuggeln
Shit, Alter
Immer der, den man nicht sieht, so ist es halt
Würdest du das Spiel inzwischen empfehlen?
Ja, die Frage kommt öfters
Und das einfachste, was ich dir drauf antworten kann
Ist, wenn du dafür schon Geld ausgegeben hast
Dann auf jeden Fall, guck es dir nochmal an
Oh shit, die haben Panzer bei uns
In der Base
Dann guck es dir auf jeden Fall nochmal an
Wenn du noch kein Geld dafür ausgegeben hast
Und du nicht glücklich wirst bei irgendeinem anderen Game
Und wirklich da dein Battlefield
Battlefield-Stelz mal wieder brauchst
Können die mal sterben, please
Dann kann ich dir empfehlen
Warte, bis es ein Sale gibt
Was anderes fällt mir nicht ein
Also zum Vollpreis kann ich es dir nicht empfehlen
Es ist immer noch ein Battlefield Lite
Und auch wenn es ein paar coole Sachen gibt
Was sie jetzt gemacht haben
Dann rede ich jetzt immer noch von
Im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten, die sie hatten
Let's break it
Break it, break it
Wir sind dead
Jawoll, der andere hat es geschafft
Also wenn das jetzt
Oh ne, der legt jetzt
Wenn das jetzt eine Beta gewesen wäre
Und die würden
Ende des Jahres releasen
Dann würde ich sagen
Wenn die sich jetzt nochmal richtig reinhängen
Und jetzt so mit dem Feedback
Aus dem Player-Test und so
Sich jetzt nochmal richtig reinhängen
Bis Ende des Jahres
Okay, alles klar, Game
Dankeschön, Pog
Dann könnte es ein ganz gutes Game werden
Alter
Wir haben einen mit 17 Kills
Der geht richtig ab, ich muss mal aufhören
Einfach sinnlos rein, wobei sinnlos reinrennen
Ist halt als Defender das Beste, was du machen kannst
Und endlich M-Comps
Wo sind denn die all?
Jetzt
Jetzt ist es weg, jetzt haben wir es verloren
Oh
Vielleicht
Vielleicht kriegen wir von der Seite
Noch ein paar Gegner kaputt, aber
Aber wir kriegen es auf jeden Fall nicht mehr
Diffused
Keine Chance
Keine Chance auf Diffuse
Ich wäre dem Game sehr verbunden, wenn die Schüsse nicht durchfliegen würden
Das wäre äußerst
Pog-Game
Aber ich verstehe auch, wenn das nicht geht
Dann
Dann müssten die Schüsse
Weiter durchfliegen
Oh fuck, oh shit
Oh
Ich habe gerade in jeder Richtung
Fünf Gegner gehabt, die mich geaimt haben
Oh, was haben wir denn hier
Ganz gute Posi, glaube ich
Alter
Was ist mit den Dudes los
Wie die hinten
Okay, der hat eine gute Posi mit dem Auto
Könnt ihr mal aufhören
Zu snipen
Hör auf, aufhören
Aufhören
Ich komme noch nicht mal zu M-Comps mehr
Okay, da können wir jetzt rein
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und können irgendwie eins der M-Comps erhalten
Okay
Was war das?
B für den Hund?
Fuck
Ey, das kann sich aber komplett knicken gerade
Alter
Die sind aber scharf, das ist richtiges
ESL Final gerade wieder
Und wir spawnen richtig besch-
Oh oh
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären
Wie der mich getroffen hat
Da war doch die Kiste
Dazwischen
Alter, die sind anstrengend
Die Gegner
Weiß gerade nicht, was ich
Ich bleibe jetzt einfach hier liegen
So
Alter, was ist das hier
Bauen die ein neues Rechenzentrum
Guckt euch das mal an
Du weißt gar nicht, wo du drauf schießen sollst
Weil
Alter, fuck
Ey man, wo soll ich
Wo soll ich hin
Was ist denn das hier gerade
Das war jetzt nicht mehr normal
Guckt euch das mal an
Du guckst aus ner Ecke, wirst aus 5
5 Richtungen angeschossen
Du guckst um die andere Richtung, 5 Richtungen
Du rennst zunächst, 5 Richtungen angeschossen
Alter
Das ist wieder
Es ist heute ESL Weekly
Guck mal
Die sind mit diesem komischen Ding schon einfach rangefahren
What
Wie
Die sind alle verwirrt
Okay, ich geh jetzt aufs Dach
Ich camp mich jetzt einfach aufs Dach
Und move nicht mehr
Ich seh da einen Sniper auf mich
Aim
Wenn er von hinten kommt, bin ich gefickt
Hat's probiert
Ich wusste nicht, auf welchen Zwei ich zielen soll
Links, rechts
Hat nicht funktioniert
Boah, die Gegner sind ja anstrengend
Meine Güte, was ist denn da los
Ich glaube, ich sollte weniger
Objectives spielen, so wie ich es eben gemacht hab
Ist die bessere Variante
Nicht, nicht, nicht aufs Objective
mich stürzen, sondern
Versuchen einfach, möglichst viele zu killen
Weil die überrennen uns sonst
Eben hat's ja kurz mal funktioniert
Wenn wir Glück haben
Können wir sogar noch ein paar abfangen
die hier hochkommen
Wenn wir Pech haben, sind wir dead
Okay
Da waren oben welche
Game? Hallo?
Game?
Ich mein, wenigstens
Ist die Progression
Erhalten geblieben
Was haben wir denn noch Schönes
Können wir mal ausprobieren
Wie das ist
Also testweise
Rusch
Hat sich der Battlefield 3
Nicht gerne, also ich hatte bei Battlefield 3
Ehrlich gesagt sehr wenig Servercrashes
Makario, ja
Im Vergleich zu Battlefield, nennen wir es mal
Standards
Dann wird das wahrscheinlich nie ein richtig gutes Battlefield werden
Das wird immer so ein Battlefield lite bleiben
Was allein schon dadurch verursacht wurde
Wie
Durch die Designentscheidungen
Die halt während der Entwicklung getroffen wurden
Das kannst du im Nachhinein nicht mehr alles ausbauen
Trotzdem, ich muss sagen
Gerade die letzte Season
Hat, also die aktuelle Season
Die vor ein paar Tagen rausgekommen ist
Horst und Mann sagen, ne ich spiel Standard Matchmaking
Die haben ein paar ganz coole Sachen
Wiedergebracht, im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten
Wenn jetzt noch
Hourglass überarbeitet wird
Dann würde ich sagen
Sind zumindest
Alle Maps irgendwie spielbar
Ich würde immer noch sagen, dass
50% der Maps Schrott sind
Dann 25%
Sagen wir mal, von den Nächsten sind
Vielleicht so 30% ganz okay
Zum Beispiel Manifest
Und es sind höchstens
20% der Maps sind vielleicht
Wo ich sagen würde, ey da hab ich richtig Bock drauf
Wenn die kommen
Wenn man mal die Legacy Maps
Weglässt, weil sie haben natürlich
Und das ist auch sinnig
Das hab ich ja auch in einem der ersten Videos
Damals schon gesagt
Sie haben natürlich wieder ganz viel Zeug recycelt
Was ja auch sinnig ist
Den alten Kram wieder reinzupacken
Du hast Valparaiso
Du hast Erika Haber
Erika Haber spielt sich beispielsweise nicht gut in dem Game
Was hast du denn sonst noch?
Ja gut, du hast Nosehair Canals
Aus Battlefield 3
Ich mein, wenn es nach mir geht
Würden die einfach alle alten Maps reinhauen
Aber so einfach ist es nicht
So einfach ist es nicht
Sie haben es ja sogar geschafft
Nosehair Canals fast unspielbar
In Rush zu machen
Weil
Nosehair Canals, die Attackerboote
Respawnen nicht richtig
Und ihr wisst ja vielleicht, in Nosehair Canals
Da spawnen die Attacker
Ich hab meine Waffe nicht customised
Wow
Und dementsprechend kannst du auf
Nosehair Canals die erste Base gar nicht richtig einnehmen
Weil du eben
Keine Boote mehr hast
Wenn der erste Push fehlgeschlagen ist
Das ist ein wenig
Bebeger
Leute, ich glaube
Wir müssen jetzt auch
Die RM8 Dingsbums rausholen
Sonst wird es wieder nichts
Sonst wird es
Wieder nächstes ESL Final
Wir müssen es anders machen
Wir sterben halt einfach nicht
Oh Gott, kein Dauerfeuer Max
Wenn du Dauerfeuer machst, bist du dead
Dead mit Dauerfeuer
Die haben disarmed
Shit, den hätte ich noch haben können
Was fändet ihr denn
Als nächstes Battlefield gut?
Wie gesagt, Modern Warfare
Also nicht das Game, sondern
Aktueller Zeitpunkt
In der Geschichte
Battlefield 2042
Ist mir fast schon ein bisschen zu futuristisch angelegt
Also ich hätte
Ich würde wirklich ein Modern Warfare Szenario
Am liebsten
Hätte ich echt am liebsten
Game, reloade mal bitte meinen Grappling Hook
Guck nochmal
Guck mal wie es durchschießt
Interessiert mich nicht
Alter, Battlefield 3
Ist Modern Warfare von 2010
Ich meine halt
Modern Warfare von heute
So 2023 rum
Okay
Der hat die gleiche Waffe, aber ich habe Silencer drauf
Lass es mir gefallen
Das ist wieder richtiges
ESL Final die Runde
Was war man da?
Da kannst du nicht richtig hoch
Einmal probiere ich es noch
Wie das der
Shit, blöde Idee Max, blöde Idee
BB
Okay, volle Pulle
Gib ihm
Okay, jetzt müssen wir hier hoch
Hier kommt jetzt ganz viel
Ah der war gut
Der war gut
Jetzt wird es aber anstrengend langsam
Jetzt wird es aber
Anstrengend langsamer
Fuck it
Das war blöd angestellt
Ich hätte locker 4 Leute killen können, hätte ich nicht so
PP geaimt
Nein, shit
Okay, close
Wir haben alles probiert was ging
Wie halt gerade 8 aus seinem Team am M kommen
Ich weiß nicht was mit den Leuten los ist
Die sind alle total blind
Was wurde aus CSGO Zeiten
Ich habe ewig kein CSGO mehr gespielt
Seit Jahren schon nicht mehr
Habe ich auch nicht so wirklich Bock drauf
Und selbst mit CS
CSGO
Heißt das eigentlich CSGO 2
Oder heißt es nur CS 2
Also selbst mit dem neuen CS
Habe ich nicht viel Bock drauf
Einfach nur CS 2
Haben sie aber nicht viel Brokers gemacht
Zwischen 1.6 und 2, oder
Haben quasi 15
20 Jahre gebraucht
Für 0,4 Versionspunkte
Es hat jemand im Chat gefragt
Wieso man das
Aimcom entschärfen sollte, wirklich
Alter
Nee, ich host kein Server
Ich spiel weiter Matchmaking
Warum sollte man das Aimcom
Entschärfen
Okay, auf our class kann ich es verstehen
Wenn man das fragt
Weil um so länger muss man die kack Map spielen
Auf our class würde ich auch die Aimcoms
Nicht entschärfen
Das könnten wir mal wieder
Spielen, lass mal kurz gucken
Also ich muss sagen, die ACR die gefällt mir gut
Mit der MTA werde ich nicht warm
Jemand hat geschrieben, MaxMTA wird neues Meta
Ich weiß nicht
Ah, guck mal da
Kills
Moment, ich muss Kills machen mit der AEK
Obwohl ich die AEK noch nicht freigespielt habe
What? Ah nee, in Portal spielen
Damit
Oder die AK24
Leute man sieht wie oft ich die AK24
Schon gespielt habe
Das ist glaube ich so meine
Favorite Assault Rifle
Wie man hier sieht
Die AK24
Da habe ich überhaupt
Keinen Bock drauf
Please, no
Wir sind Defender
Schon zum zweiten Mal our class
Die letzten zwei Streams
Wurden wir fast verschont davon
Es gab
Ich glaube vorgestern gar kein
Our Class und gestern einmal
Ja, ich spiele in Anfang der Runde
Und wenn das irgendwie sackt
Dann leave ich direkt
Das Our Class Rework wird das alles in Ordnung bringen
Wie
Fast wie der Angriff Steiner
Das Our Class
Rework wird das alles
Wieder in Ordnung bringen
Das Our Class Rework ist nicht erfolgt
Das kommt eh noch in dem nächsten Patch
Our Class war zu kaputt
Wir können Our Class nicht fixen
Oh, oh, oh
Lege Hände
Wir sind schon unterwegs zu A
Okay, was auch immer
Boah, mein Poppes ist eingeschlafen
Muss mich mal kurz umsetzen
Vielleicht
Können wir das ja schnell beenden
Indem wir einfach
Schön spawn up campen
Okay, der Schuss von dem ich gedacht habe
Dass er garantiert kein Hit wurde, wurde ein Hit
Sehr schön
Vielleicht liegt es aber auch einfach am Schalldämpfer
Mein Schalldämpfer als Defense hier auf der Range
Ist eigentlich total
Total hängen geblieben, ne
Wie das, habt ihr gesehen
Wie es durch den Kopf geflogen ist
Das fliegt einfach durch den Kopf
Shit
Seit 10
Seit 10 Monaten Our Class zu spielen
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung
Einfach Our Class zu
Rage quitten
Immer wenn das kommt
Da hast du eigentlich recht
Das ist eine gute Idee
Das ist
Eine richtig und wichtige Entscheidung
Wie man heute so schön sagt
Aber wir haben es gleich
Wir haben sie gleich spawn camped
Kein Problem
Spawn camp stellt es regelt
Die Maps gleich vorbei
Auch wenn das nicht so aussieht
Wie soll ich denn eigentlich tappen
Dass es funktioniert
Das macht aber kein Damage
Panzer
Ist kein Gegner
Panzer ist tot
Perfekt
33 Tickets noch, gleich haben wir es geschafft
Ich renn da jetzt einfach rüber
Guck mal, wir stehen quasi schon fast im spawn
Du triffst nichts
Doch, macht er
Was eine Rotzmap
Man sieht, dass das Game
Teilweise ganz gute Ansätze hat
Zum Beispiel hier das mit den Fußspuren
Im Sand und sowas
Das ist tatsächlich ganz hübsch gemacht
Wo ist denn hier was
Sehe nichts
Gegner
Oh shit
Der Enterhaken und mit diesem
Bunnyhopping light ist ganz praktisch
Dann treffen die einen eigentlich meistens nicht
Wenn du die Straße überquerst
Andere Seite
Oh da ist der Panzer
Schlechte Idee
Dahin zu pushen
Pass mal auf
Damit rechnet er jetzt nicht
Damit rechnet er nicht
Hehehe
Komm vielleicht retzt du mich
Kollege du kannst mich retzen
Pog
Damit hab ich nicht gerechnet
Damit hab ich
Pepega aimed gegen ihn
Perfekt
Pog Position
Das ist
Das ist das Gegenteil von der Pole Position
Maximap please
Was eine Rotzmap
Alter die ist so schlecht
Chat
Eure Meinung zu Hourglass und was sollen sie reworken
Ich glaube das
Soll ich mal ernsthaft sagen was ich glaube
Ich glaube, was das beste Rework ist von Hourglass
Und nein, ich meine nicht die Map löschen
Ich glaube das beste Rework von Hourglass ist
Das Thema der Map zu nehmen
Also diese, diese, was ist denn das, ähm
Dubai oder so
Dubai Wüsten Map
Und dann ein neues Gebiet bauen
Die könnten so eine Art Metro Map zum Beispiel bauen
Irgendein bisschen Außengebiet und dann unterirdisches Battle und sowas
Die müssen glaube ich eine neue Map bauen
Hourglass selbst ist einfach Schrott
Und sie könnten Hourglass auch gleich umbauen in eine 64-Spieler-Karte
Und dann hätten sie vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr Ideen
Die sollten die Idee, dass das Thema von der Map nehmen und einfach ein neues Gebiet bauen
Ich glaube viel kannst du an Hourglass nicht mehr recyceln
Die Map ist einfach Schrott
Kaleidoskop, die ist auch Schrott, aber die ist auf anderem Niveau Schrott als Hourglass
Also Kaleidoskop ist Schrott, aber Hourglass ist quasi
Sollte man eigentlich deaktivieren bis zum Rework Schrott
Uh
Mal Attacker auf der Map, nice
Gestern nur 50 mal Defended
Kam ja gefühlt jede zweite Runde gestern, Kaleidoskop
Büp
Probier das doch mal mit Silencer jetzt
Ich überhole euch alle noch, Leute
Ey, nicht Cheaten
Was ist das hier? Unfunly
So geht das nicht
Nicht hier Speedhacken
Ey
Jetzt kommt der einfach und macht Gutschy Bass von hinten
Der Sack
Nice, Dankeschön Game
Okay, ich werd nicht
Gibt kein Rätzke
Oh Mist
Die, die, die, die, die wollen es aber richtig wissen hier die Defender
An der ersten Base
Ja, das war nix
Ich geh doch nicht hoch
Ich versuche mal zu A zu pushen
Und wenn ich Glück hab, klappt es
Ich glaube nicht, dass es was wird
Alter
Wie schnell die mich killen
Okay, komm, rein jetzt hier
Beste
So, wir machen jetzt einfach mal den Schalldämpfer ab
Ich glaube, der Sack da
Fucking Shotgun
Der hatte den Highground, da kannst du nix machen
Oh, die Runde läuft ja richtig
Beste Runde ever
Hab so ein bisschen Schiss, hier raus zu gehen
Lege Hände, lege Hände, lege Hände
Nice
Lege Hände
Oh, da hinten sind ja noch einige
Wow, close, close
So, wir kommen jetzt hier am besten rüber
Lange
Gar keinen Attack haben wir hier gespielt
Okay, wir rennen einfach, wie verrückt
Geradeaus, YOLO
Und hoffen, es hittet uns niemand
Weil die kommen ja nicht hier hoch
Ich bin begeistert, wie gut die treffen
Okay
Okay, du denkst, ich gehe links
Ha!
She baited
Aber leider von der Seite gesniped
Das ist das, was
Das sind so die kleinen Momente, die ich in Battlefield echt mag
Wenn du denkst
Der Gegner denkt, dass ich denke, dass er links geht
Und dann bleibst du halt rechts drauf
Und das klappt
Das ist dann immer
Ein
Fuck
Battlefield
Ihr könnt mich retzen, das spart uns ein Ticket
Das sollte nicht so schwierig sein
Ich liege hier voll in Deckung
Okay, naja, anscheinend doch nicht
Ich habe so meine Probleme gerade
Irgendwie hier durchzukommen
Ich hoffe, die können rein spawnen bei mir
Ich war mal
Kriechmodus
Stelz-Mode
Activated
Oh
Ich habe Schiss, Leute
What?
Was?
Bitte nicht
Besch
Bescheißt der?
Ich meine, wie um alles in der Welt hat er mich da gesehen und hat gehittet?
3D-Spotting?
Das ist das einzige, was ich mir da vorstellen kann
Keine Ahnung
Okay, nice
Next game
Das wird so doof gerade
Rusch
Ja, was können wir mal spielen?
Ähm
Soll ich mal
Ich will wirklich die AEK frei spielen
Ich meine, 100 Kills gehen
Was machen wir dann so im Durchschnitt pro Attacker-Runde so
Kills
Vielleicht im Durchschnitt
Oh, Caspian Border
20 Kills im Durchschnitt vielleicht
Das heißt, in 5 Runden
Dann habe ich die AEK frei
Das müsste eigentlich gehen
Rusch, Attacker, Caspian Border
Jawohl
Haben wir noch nie gespielt
Gibt es gerade Rush XL
Ich weiß nicht, wo sieht man, wo es irgendwas gibt
Ich nehme einfach im Hauptmenü die
Quickplay-Liste und gut ist
Ja, Solo vs. Bots habe ich letztens im Stream was unlockt
Das ist aber so dumm
Also ich verstehe übrigens auch nicht, warum das überhaupt möglich ist, gegen Bots zu unlocken
Weil entweder sagst du, okay
Du baust das ein
Und du willst, dass die Leute was unlocken müssen
Mit halt einer gewissen
Anforderung
Das ist okay
Oder
Alles klar
Oder du lässt es gleich weg
Weil wenn du es gegen Bots machen kannst, ist es halt sinnlos
Da kannst du auch einfach gleich unlocken für alle
Das ist ein Vorteil
Das geht hier noch flüssiger als mit Battlefield 3
Battlefield 3 hat halt richtig rumgezuckelt
Wow
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt
Na super
Geile Pose, um uns auszusetzen
Ganz toll
Da kommen wir doch nie im Leben
Nie im Leben
Lebend
An
Über das Feld, wo wir hier rennen müssen
Guck dir das an
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Nice
Oh
Headbanger
Da unten sind ein paar
Wenn wir Glück haben, sind schon ein paar in der Base
Nein, wir sind sonst wo, man
Gegen gescheite Gegner klappt das nie
Die sehen, wo man runter geht und bashen einen sofort
Aber vielleicht haben wir Glück und sind keine gescheiten Gegner
YOLO
Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip
Ich glaube, die sind viel zu sehr mit ihrem Panzerkrempel beschäftigt da drüben
What the fuck, Alter
Wie, wie soll ich
Wie, wie, wie
Ich verstehe die Assault Rifles nicht mehr
War das, oder war das, war da eine Kiste dazwischen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Nice, wir haben es
Au
Oh, schnell hier rein
Wenn wir Glück haben, kommen wir jetzt noch hier in die
Oh, shit
Ist auch schwierig, hier rüber zu kommen
Ja, ja, ja, okay
Wenigstens einer ein bisschen hier dran
Nice
Wenn wir Glück haben
Wieder richtige ESL Finals am Start
Wie, der ist ernsthaft nicht gestorben, ja gerade
Das kann sich ja mal voll knicken
Die sind, die sind wieder richtig
Wie, wie, wie, wie
Wie, wie, wie hat er mich getroffen?
Ist das Game, ich verstehe es gerade nicht
Ich liege hinter einem Betonteil
Es ist gerade wirklich jede Runde übelstes ESL Final
Oh, wir sind im Panzer, wir haben einen Panzer am Start
Vielleicht, vielleicht haben wir da irgendwie
Oh, oh, oh
Nice, guter Spawn
50%, nice
Das ist so krass gerade
Es ist null Aufbau in dem Game drinnen
Was, was willst du machen?
Oh, das, what the f...
Was ist hier
Ich meine, was willst du machen?
Was willst du tun, würde der echte Gangster jetzt sagen
Nix
Wie im Hühnerstall, echt so
Ich meine, warum, die können ja wenigstens bei mir reinspawnen hier
Aber die spawnen nicht bei mir rein
Die spawnen da oben rein
Warum?
Da ist ein Panzer
Also du hast in dieser Runde wirklich keine Chance, irgendwas zu machen
Unsere Leute sind dead?
Guckst du dir an
Ich habe Schiss, mich hier überhaupt rauszubewegen, man
Rambo-Move, ja
Komm mal, ich strecke, ich strecke meinen Kopf raus, bin dead
Krass, oder?
What the f... man
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht können wir jetzt ran
Okay, volle Pulle
Die Gegner, man
Du kannst ja hier keine 5 Meter laufen ohne...
Dead
Leute, ich habe alles versucht
Echt, mehr ging nicht
Ich habe, ich habe wirklich alles probiert
Oh, das war krass, Alter
Na gut, meisten Kills, alle Objectives gelegt, die wir gekriegt haben, mehr konnte ich nicht machen
Na okay, meisten Kills immer auf der Seite
F, ja
Der Typ sieht ein bisschen aus
Wie der
Ich weiß nicht, welcher Specialist das war
Der sah ein bisschen aus wie der Held aus MW 2019
Promoted to Squad Leader, yeah
Da habe ich drauf gewartet, geil, und jetzt werden wir wieder rausgeworfen und nächste Runde Matchmaking
Ich finde es übrigens auch blöd, dass man nicht mehr so random mit den Leuten einfach zusammenspielen kann über ein paar Runden, weil man halt auf dem gleichen Server ist
Die meisten Auto-Balancer, die es gab für Battlefield 3
Hatten ein Setting und die meisten Server haben das auch eingeschaltet
Wenn möglich, keep squads together, wenn das nicht zu übertrieben wird
Und das hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert
Und das fand ich auch eine gute Sache
Weil du konntest im Endeffekt mit random Leuten, die du kennengelernt hast, ohne dass ihr euch irgendwie ändern musstet in Friendlist, neue Lobby suchen, neues Game suchen
Konnten einfach weiter draufbleiben auf dem Server
Und du hast dann mit den gleichen Leuten spielen können eine Weile
Das hat sich einfach so spontan ergeben, das fand ich eine gute Sache
Zumindest bei den Servern in Battlefield 3, wo die Leute es eingeschaltet haben
Jetzt aktuell, Battlefield 3 wird übrigens das nächste sein, was abgeschaltet wird, realistisch betrachtet
BC2 ist weg
Und Battlefield 3 hat auch noch kaum Spieler, also wahrscheinlich ist das bald R.I.P. BF3
Aber zumindest gibt es für Battlefield 3 schon Alternativen
Vielleicht spielen da ein paar Leute mehr Venice, mal gucken
Für Bad Company 2 brauchst du eigentlich keine wirklichen Alternativen, weil es ja eh schon self-hosted Server gibt
Also wo man wirklich auch mit Server-Software, die jeder haben kann zum hosten
Ist halt wahrscheinlich die Sache mit dem Master-Server, aber ansonsten dürfte es mit BC2 eigentlich relativ schnell die ein oder anderen Server geben, die man
Wir gehen rüber zu A, weil meistens rennen alle zu B und an A ist kaum jemand
Ist das schon
Commander-Krieger-Aim, Alter, hätte man da früher zugesagt
Keckel
Hallo, lass mich mal an dem spawnen
Das habe ich schon mal gelesen, ja, mit den gleichen Leuten
Wie Venice
Ich meine, ich habe es probiert
Ich meine, ich habe es probiert, Leute
Ich habe es probiert
Ich dachte, es ist ein Gegner
Wo ist hier was?
Ich sehe nichts
Da drüben sind sie
Mann, warum hat das Ding nicht auf meine Shotgun geswitzt?
Ihr habt doch die Switch-Animation gesehen, oder?
Der hat rübergegriffen zur Shotgun und hat auf einmal wieder das Assault-Rifle rausgeholt
What?
Danke, Game
Ich warte jetzt, bis die hier rauskommen und spreche euch weg
Die müssen ja hier rauskommen
Passt auf
Machen sie nicht
Okay, fast
Ich habe den nicht gesehen durch das Gitter
Okay, nice
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir hier was
Oh, da drüben sind jede Menge
Da drüben sind richtig viele
Seht ihr das?
Da waren bestimmt acht Gegner gerade
Wir machen mal CS-Smoke-Schieß-Style
Jetzt ist aber mal gut
Jetzt hört mal auf, hier so rumzusmoken
Counter-Smoke
Ich höre was unter mir
Leute, ich habe komplett die Übersicht verloren
Ich wusste null, wo der Typ hin ist
Boomer-Hirn überfordert, eindeutig
Habt ihr gerade gesehen, so sieht es aus mit fast 39
Warum streamst du so viel? Warum nicht?
Wow
Wenn wir Glück haben
Lässt mich das Game einen von den Dudes anklicken
Und ich kann da spawnen
Ne, overrated, outdated, shebaited, das gibt es nicht
Das ist überhaupt kein Danger
Hör auf zu lügen, Game
Börnge
Okay, vielleicht
Haben wir Glück
Und können uns irgendwo hier oben langstelzen
In der Hoffnung, dass hier gerade frei ist
Und erwischen da was?
Aber auf der Seite smoken wir mal ab
Nice Assault Rifles, gg
Wie voll sind eigentlich die Server?
Naja, nachdem ich über Matchmaking gehe, sind die immer voll
Wie viele Spieler es insgesamt gibt, ja, fraglich
Alter
Das war nicht der gleiche
Das war ein anderer
Steam sagt 12k, ja na gut
Es lohnt sich jetzt zu spielen
Also jetzt oder nie, Leute
Weil jetzt ist gerade halt die neue Season
Rekt
YOLO, YOLO Rats
Easy, win
Nice, alle weggesprayt zum Schluss nochmal
Ich muss sagen, die secondary Shotgun ist schon nice
Gerade für solche Situationen
Du kannst halt einfach mal relativ schnell zwei Leute one shotten
Und wenn viel los ist, dann bringt das auch was
Aber nur dritter Platz
WilderTiger95
Also, ernsthaft, mir könnte kein größerer casual Name einfallen
Als WilderTiger85
Äh, 95
Das ist so der typische Familienvater, der zwei Stunden in der Woche mal spielen kann
Und ein bisschen Battlefield zockt
20, okay, sieben Level noch
Bis zur KekW
Nice
Einfach mal so ein bisschen
Eine Patchy Skin, yeah
Da hab ich drauf gewartet
Ich denke, ihr auch
Ihr wollt mich bestimmt alle mal Heli fliegen sehen, oder?
Ist das Battlefield 2042?
Ja
Mir fällt leider kein blöder Gag ein, was das sonst sein könnte
Ja, es ist Battlefield 2042
Guck mal, wie leblos der Hintergrund aussieht
Die Szenen werden ja in dem Level-Editor so erstellt
Dass du eh nur diesen Ausschnitt siehst
So, hier drumherum ist halt nix
Es gibt halt exakt diesen Ausschnitt
Gut, ich mein, vielleicht ist es ein Teil von der Map
Aber man hat die nochmal schön gemacht
Oh, nein!
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das spielen wir jetzt nicht
Aber es sieht halt trotzdem komplett leblos aus
No!
No, god, please, no!
Wir spielen nicht Hourglass
Das ist das dritte Mal Hourglass heute
Ne, oder das wäre glaube ich sogar das vierte Mal Hourglass jetzt
Nein
Also ich hoffe, mal angenommen an den Gerüchten ist was dran
Also, dass Ende nächsten Jahres noch ein Battlefield, ein weiteres Battlefield kommen soll
Dann hoffe ich
Sie machen ein Modern Warfare Setting
So in der jetzigen Zeit und mit den jetzigen Sachen, die so benutzt werden
Und dann halt umfangreich in Richtung Battlefield 4
Dass man einfach mal sieht, okay, wir müssen nicht jedes Mal das Rad neu erfinden
Das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was ich bei der Battlefield Entwicklung nie verstehe
Wir müssen nicht das Rad neu erfinden
Wir können einfach mal ein solides Game abliefern
Wo wir die Dinge halt so machen, wie wir wissen, dass sie halt eben ganz gut funktionieren
Aber was anderes
Wisst ihr, ich hab bei jedem Battlefield Teil, der programmiert wird von DICE
Immer das Gefühl, die fangen irgendwie immer bei Null an
Gut, mal von Frostbite abgesehen, aber die fangen irgendwie immer bei Null an
So, ah, wie machen wir das jetzt mit den Klassen diesmal gescheit?
Ah, wie machen wir das Waffenhandling gescheit?
Und, oh, wie können wir eine gute Battlefield Map bauen?
Ah, ich weiß nicht, wie das geht
Dann müssen wir erstmal auf ein dreiwöchiges Teambuilding-Workshop fahren
Dass uns vielleicht einfällt, ob wir nicht immer eine gute Map machen
Aber Leute, ihr macht den Scheiß seit 30 Jahren
Äh, okay
Die haben ernsthaft fast schon...
Die sind schneller, als die Defender an den M-Comps, das ist halt auch Fail, ne?
PP-29
Leute, die holen wir jetzt raus
Passt mal auf
Ewig nicht gespielt, wo ist das Ding?
PP-29, let's go
Na gut, ich hab versucht, beide zu erwischen
Okay, was macht man auf dieses Ding am besten drauf?
Silencer ist es nicht
Leute, äh
High Power, Effective Range, Rate of Fire
Okay, das Ding
64, jawoll, geb ihm
Schießt das auch schnell? Moment, der versucht gerade zu flanken
Was ist denn hier los?
Nein, das war nicht nur Netcode, Leute
Das war definitiv nicht nur Netcode
Fuck it, fuck it, fuck it
Alter, das ist ja mal gut
Achtung, Spritze
Okay, ich darf den nicht retzen
Ich bin übrigens gemarkert
Okay, nice
Aber die erste Base haben wir tatsächlich ganz gut
Okay, ich hab lange keine SMGs mehr gespielt
Shit, hier sind 30 Milliarden Gegner
Hör ich um mich drum herum gerade
Nee, das sind meine Teammates
Okay, stelzen wir uns mal hier rum
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo man am besten rum geht
Wow
Schlechte Idee, Max
Ganz schlechte Idee
Alter
Das geht gerade gar nicht mit dem Ding, Alter
Aber bleiben wir mal an B, bleiben wir mal an B
Schnell durch
Leute, ich kann, ich kann kein Ding machen
Leute, ich kann, ich kann keinen Nahkampf mehr gerade
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn
Ich treffe nix mit dem Ding
Okay, Shotgun nicht, fuck, dead
Das habe ich verkackt
Oh oh, wir sind gleich alle dead
Nice Claymore
Warum setzt man da eine Claymore hin?
Das ist die beschissenste Position ever für eine Claymore
Okay, nice
Ich weiß zwar nicht, ich weiß zwar nicht, wie wir diese Runde gewonnen haben
Aber wir haben sie gewonnen
Also an mir lag es auf jeden Fall nicht, dass wir gewonnen haben
Das war wirklich, oh oh oh, links, rechts, links, rechts, irgendwie
Das war die Challenge
Wie schafft man es, mehr vorbeizuschießen an einem Gegner als drauf zu bleiben
Obwohl man den Gegner eigentlich treffen will
Ja, das war extremstes, extremstes hier
Aber SMG-Nahkampf macht auch mal wieder Bock
Nach irgendwie 100 Runden Assault Rifle only
Hat man in dem Game eigentlich mittlerweile irgendwie Statistiken oder so?
Damage, Punkte, KD und sowas
Profile
Oh, nochmal Caspian Border Attacker
Vielleicht
Denkst du, das Game lohnt sich mittlerweile?
Wenn du es schon gekauft hast, auf jeden Fall
Wenn du es noch nicht gekauft hast, würde ich sagen, warte mal, bis es im Sale ist
Profile, Statistiken, okay
Zweier KD, nee
Ja
Ziemlich genau, ja
Da hätte ich früher sofort meine Statistiken geresettet
Wie viel Schuss hat denn da was?
Extended
Okay
Ähm
Ja, ganz schlau
Jetzt habe ich keine Autos, kein Auto und nichts
War letztens für 15 Euro
Ja, für 15 Euro kann man sich das durchaus mal gönnen
Ich finde, 15 Euro ist ein guter Preis
Nee, 15 Euro ist okay
15, 20 Euro ist gut
Also die 60 Euro oder sowas, die da standardmäßig in Steam noch haben wollen, ist absolut bescheuert
Würde ich im Leben nicht dafür ausgeben
Und jetzt im Nachhinein erst rechnen
Ja klar, Game
Äh, jetzt erst rechnen, weil
Die hatten am Anfang bei mir richtig viel Bonus
Weil ich mir gedacht habe, geil, neues Battlefield Trailer, sieht geil aus
Und das Beste an dem Spiel
Müsst ihr, müsst ihr jetzt einfach einfach einfach einfach einfach
Das Beste an dem Spiel war ja auch der Trai
War ja auch der Trailer
Shit
Das Trailer Team hat richtig gecarried, ja
Der Trailer, Trailer war einfach das Beste an dem ganzen Game
Okay, vielleicht kommen wir, vielleicht kommen wir da durch
Shit
Dachte, der Erste ist tot
Jetzt rushen sie aber richtig das Ding hier, die Hütte
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Nee, wir gehen bei dem rein
Wir gehen bei dem rein
Alter, was ist das für einer?
Au
Lege Hände
Bin unschlüssig von wo
Aber gut, nice
Oh, ganz viel um mich drumherum hier
Okay, vielleicht kommen wir jetzt hier rüber
Nein, der fucking Claymore wieder
Der Claymore Typ, der legt die auch sonst wo immer hin, oder?
1080p hochskaliert, sieht auf 1440 schlecht aus
Quatsch
Das sieht vollkommen okay aus
Saved
Hinter mir ist ein Panzer
Ich hab Schiss
Aber nice, wir haben Legehände gemacht, hat funktioniert
Reinsporn, nice
Next
Moin, Enki
Gigachat Objective Players, ja
So, es müsste eigentlich aufgehen, bis wir vorne sind
Okay, wir sind vorne
Wir sind vorne
Bis wir vorne sind
Wir machen jetzt weiter, Gigachat Objective Player
Hier gab es Squad Rush in der Base
Kann sich noch irgendjemand an Squad Rush erinnern?
Ich bin übrigens der Meinung, Squad Rush
Ist der einzige Modus
Der irgendwie zu nem Battlefield Esport getaugt hätte
Conquest wär nix gewesen
Oh fuck, alter, shit
Ah, zu spät gesehen
Conquest taucht nix
Ähm
Das, äh, oder, oder
Domination taucht nix
Ich finde Squad Rush wär der einzige Modus gewesen, der irgendwie ein bisschen was
Dafür getaugt hätte
Müssten eigentlich noch Gegner sein, ne?
Sind sie nicht
Alle dead
Doch
Alter, ich treff nix
Pepega hoch 10, ja
Aber nice, hier kann man vorne direkt bei dem reinste...
Nein, please, lass mich spawnen
Oh, Hazard Zone, hör mal bloß auf, lul, alter
Hazard Zone war ja an, an, an
An Pepega Points kaum noch zu übertreffen, ne?
Hazard Zone war so ein Ding
Das hat die erste Runde Spaß gemacht
Und danach hast du dir eigentlich gedacht
Warum spiel ich das überhaupt?
Das hat nicht lang gehalten
What the
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben
Jawoll
Lege Henne
Ich muss mich mal kurz verstecken
In der Hoffnung, es können paar Leute rein spawnen bei mir
Ach, die leben alle noch
Okay
Shit
Hätte klappen können
Einer noch übrig
Ah, nice, nice, nice
Mein Team lebt, glaube ich, auch noch
Wenn wir Glück haben, können wir direkt hier rein spawnen
Ja, nice
Guck mal, wir waren fast dran
Wir waren fast am B
Wir haben nur noch 57
Komm, das geht
Ich meine, die haben es clever gemacht
Die haben das ganze Ding zerstört, ne?
Oh, shit, links der Panzer
Umkehr ist, was ist hier los?
Oh
Okay, nice
Eine richtig nice Lege Henne
Voll führt
Wow, ähm, nein, da wollte ich nicht hin
Aber okay
Ganz, ganz schlechte Idee
Ich hab's, ich hab's
Wow, close
Richtig close
Richtig close Sache gewesen
Okay, jetzt paar A rein, wenn wir Glück haben
Pork
Nice
What?
Alter
Oder wie ich das machen soll mit den Assault Rifles, ey
Okay, Shotgun in the face hat nicht funktioniert
Nice, Panzer
Panzer von hinten
Gib ihm
Warum, warum, warum ist die
Warum ist das Panzer MG eigentlich so schlecht?
Wenn's trifft, macht's kein Damage
Sag mal, warum ist das Panzer MG so schlecht?
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh
Okay, jetzt YOLO-Modus
Jetzt wird Lege Henne fabriziert
Lege Henne-Modus
Jawohl
Planten
Uh
Ich werf da ne Granate drauf, sobald's geht
Okay, ich weiß nicht, von wo das gekommen ist
Aber vielleicht sollten, vielleicht, wir sollten's schaffen, denk ich
Ich, ich denke, wir sollten A bekommen
Nice, wir haben's
Richtig wilde Markiere am Start
Rekt hat er mich
Battlefield sieht ganz okay aus
Ja, es ist immer noch ein Battlefield Lite
Das wird auch nie was anderes werden
Wow
Oh, fuck, den hab ich nicht ge-
Wo? Ich seh den immer noch nicht
Ach da!
Im Busch!
Äh
Okay, nice
Nice Game, GG
Shit, die liegen schon da oben rum
Ob das nächste Battlefield zu Release noch schlimmer wird?
Nee, das glaub ich nicht
Das ist kaum noch zu toppen
In Fail
Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass uns wieder alle restlos begeis- begeistern
Hallo, Game, please
Restlos begeistern wird, das glaub ich auch nicht
Oh, das sind ja nur 20
Wie das sagt, richtig
Nice, wir haben's gleich
Au!
Oh nee, shit!
Okay, wir haben's doch noch gekriegt
Close, close
Kann ich mir mal recken, please?
Achtung
Cock Rats
Jawohl
Spritze
Muss diesen dummen Schalldämpfer runter machen, der nervt mich
Der macht zu wenig Damage auf Range
Shit, alter!
Der Dude, ne?
Ich hab-
Game, please, lass mich doch da wieder hin
Okay, noch 8
Hört ihr euch auf, wie viele Headshots man eigentlich aus Versehen macht in dem Game?
Ich kann den nicht retten
Ich seh ihn nicht, ich seh ihn nicht
Da, da ist er, okay
Scoreboard ist extremes Legacy Feature
Ich weiß gar nicht, was sich die Spieler sich so anstellen
Aber Squad Management gibt es jetzt, Leute
Es gibt ja Squad Management
Legacy Feature ist wieder drin
Team wechseln kannst du halt noch nicht
Aber, aber Squad Management ist wieder drin
Okay, jetzt, jetzt
Okay, jetzt, jetzt geht's hier
Nice, Legehennen ist raus
Haben wir geplantet
Oh, der
Also wenn die defusen
Nein, nein, nein
Nein, Leute
Lasst die nicht defusen
Ist fast alles dead gerade
Die haben defused
Alter, ich fass es nicht
Wie können die das defuse?
Da standen 50 Leute von uns
Äh, okay
Ganz schlechte Idee, Max
Ganz schlechte Idee
Okay, nochmal Glück gehabt
Nochmal Glück gehabt
Drei Tickets, Leute, drei Tickets
Das wird nix, das wird nix
Das geht nur auf direktem Weg
Direkt YOLO
Keine Chance, was anderes zu machen
Shit
Wir hätten es eigentlich haben müssen
Aber es hat keiner auf's MCON mehr geschossen
Hast du dich jetzt eigentlich entschieden bezüglich Diablo 4?
Nö
Ich werde das auch spielen, erst
Also ich kauf mir das jetzt erstmal nicht
Ich hab nicht wirklich Bock drauf
Also wo ich, wo ich mich mega drauf freue ist Path of Exile 2
Und wenn Diablos, äh, wenn Diablo 4 irgendwie zeigen sollte
Es taugt langfristig was
Dass es sich auch mal lohnt dann die Season ordentlich zu grinden oder so
Dann hol ich's mir vielleicht noch
Aber so eher nicht
Es ist aber gut für Blizzard
Dass sie mal wieder ein Game rausgehauen haben
Was irgendwie den Ansprüchen gerecht geworden ist
Zumindest initial erstmal
Blizzard hat die letzten Jahre über ja im Prinzip nix gehabt
Ich glaube, wie ist denn das aktuelle World of Warcraft Addon?
Ich glaube, das soll auch wieder ganz gut sein
So seit Jahren mal wieder ein gescheites Addon
Wie läuft's im neuen Job? Ganz gut
Morgen muss ich wieder arbeiten
Montags, äh, na Overwatch 2 hat ja auch
Overwatch 2 kann's ja knicken
Also Overwatch ist das letzte gute Game
Jetzt vielleicht bis Diablo 4 was Blizzard so rausgehauen hat
Das WoW Addon ist gut, aber jetzt gerade nicht mehr so viel los
Warum?
Das kam doch erst, oder?
Kam das nicht erst vor einem halben oder irgendwie vor ein paar Monaten?
Overwatch 2 soll in Season 6 PvE-Content bekommen
Ja, wahrscheinlich dann, wenn Hourglass eine gute Map ist
Das ist, okay, also wenn das Addon wirklich im Oktober kam
Dann ist es eigentlich ziemlich kacke
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass es jetzt schon wieder outdated ist
Das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem bei Games
Oder gerade bei MMOs
MMOs, wo der hauptsächliche Content ist
Kreiselcrind, um Kreiselcrind zu machen, wisst ihr wie ich mein?
Deswegen mag ich eigentlich lieber MMOs, die so ein bisschen Sandbox-mäßig sind
Wo du halt selbst gucken musst
MonkaS, PPGaimed ist das Todes
Ich hätte nicht in den Chat gucken sollen
Also ich hab jahrelang Dark Age of Camelot gespielt, falls das jemand kennt
Ich hab sogar ab und zu im Stream ein paar Runden gespielt schon
Ähm, Moment, warum hab ich da eine...
Das Ding sackt mit Silence einmal richtig aber auch
Alter, was ist denn hier los? Werden wir gerade gespawn-raped? Kann das sein?
Okay, ich seh nix, da ist zu viel Sonne
Jetzt hab ich die Waffe gewechselt, Leute, ich werd müde langsam
Hoomer, kann ich länger als zweieinhalb Stunden konzentriert spielen?
Wo sind eigentlich unsere ganzen Leute?
Shit, Alter!
Ich wollte eigentlich in das Auto von denen rein
Lass mich in das Car
What the hell, Alter, hier oben geht's ja mal richtig zur Sache
Nice, nice
Legehenne
Die Legehenne ist zurück
Ich merk's echt, es ist...
Es ist echt hart, ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig konzentrieren jetzt nach zweieinhalb Stunden
Das war früher für mich gar kein Problem
Da konnt ich stundenlang spielen, es hat mich nicht gejuckt
Ja, nice
Du hast Fiberkey gekauft, wie ich sehe, sehr gut
Legit... Legit erworben, würd ich sagen
Oder?
Legit erworben, den Key, klar
So wie man's machen sollte
Boah, wie die streuen, Mann
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
In your face
Pass mal auf
Es ist Zeit, Leute
Pepega 29 time
Schlechte Idee, hier rein zu spawnen, ne?
Alter, ich kann mit dem Ding im Nahkampf nicht ziehen, das funktioniert nicht
Ich aime mich so krass, wenn ich schnell justieren muss, die Dinger
Das klappt so nicht, Leute, ich krieg kein SMG gerade hin
Was heißt, ich krieg... Wir kriegen grad nichts gebacken
Guck mal, wir haben keinerlei Gameaufbau
Wir rennen einzeln rein und sterben
Kann man das Gebäude nicht zerstören, welches?
Die Dinger, oder du kannst die Rakete starten lassen
Das wird nix, ich merk das gleich
Okay
Nice, nice, nice
Shit
Jetzt sind sie dead
Das Schild, Mensch
Shit
Fuck
Wir haben keinen Aufbau
Wir legen, aber das wird nix
Absolut kein Gameaufbau, es ist nur noch nur rein, nur reinrennen
Und instant dead
Kopf raus, Kopf raus und dead
Guck mal hier, wir fahren wieder rein, wir sind dead, bevor wir ankommen
Das hat keinen Sinn gerade
Da kannst du auch nicht wirklich viel machen, außer reinrennen und sterben
Das suckt halt mal
Hallo, ich will...
Game, ich will in das Auto
Wir müssen jetzt ran, Leute, das hat keinen Sinn, dass wir hier irgendwie rumhampeln
Wir müssen ran
Ich renne jetzt einfach durch, in der Hoffnung, es wird was
Nice
Es sind halt auch schlaue Gegner, die nicht reinrennen, obwohl ich da prefire
Nope, keine Chance
Warum darf ich jetzt nicht leaven?
Please, ich würde gerne ein neues Game suchen
Hallo, neues Game
Äh
Habe ich gerade was gesagt?
Moment, ist escape push to talk oder...
Ah, nee, alt ist push to talk
Keckel
Erstmal aufregen
Exit to menu
Lass mal kurz was checken
Wie kann man push to talk ausschalten?
Ich habe ja...
Sag mal, ich habe das doch gestern ausgeschaltet, ich bin doch gestern extra hier rein
Ah, nee, push to talk ist an, okay
Input device
Wir stellen einfach mal ein Input device ein
Wo es nichts zu inputten gibt
Kann auch nichts passieren
Push
Doch, du hast recht, das war bei Battle Bit, war das, ja
Du hast recht
Aber bei Battlefield war...
Ich weiß noch, ich habe nämlich...
Ich habe euch doch gefragt, wo ist das Soundmenü
Und ich habe es hier nicht gefunden, dass hier oben voice chat ist
Eigentlich kann man es einfach ausschalten, wenn es gut ist
Weil niemand benutzt voice chat in dem Game
Voice chat, ge
Leaf, ge
Ich spiele jetzt sicherlich kein Hourglass
Dauert sicher bis August, bis man endlich Hourglass spielen kann
Ich glaube, Hourglass wird selbst nach dem Rework nichts
Das Beste, was sie machen könnten für Hourglass
Wäre aus meiner Sicht
Die Idee, der Map beibehalten
Irgendwie so Metropole, Dubai und Wüste
Und ein neues Gebiet bauen
Und dann auch nur für 64 Spieler
Mein 128 ist eh dead
Ich glaube, das passt ganz gut
Ist richtig, 3head, 128
Bewerbungsgespräch in 30 Minuten
Bin so aufgeregt
Als was, bewerbst du dich?
Frag einfach
Und auch gerade Wubblos geguckt auf Twitch
Da sagen die, ja, klar
Jetzt habe ich ein Vorstellungsgespräch mit dir
Ich wollte eigentlich weitergucken
Backendentwickler Java
Du hast doch einen mega Plan von Java
Du warst doch hier schon öfters im Stream
Und hast manchmal ein bisschen Java
Naja, beworben ist das falsche Wort
Mir gut zugeredet, dass Java doch nicht so kacke ist
Easy, easy win
Tommy, die suchen händeringend Leute
Es ist eher so, dass die dich überzeugen müssen
Zu ihnen zu kommen, anstatt es umgedreht
Nice
Aber, ich wünsche dir nicht viel Glück
Weil Glück brauchen nur die Noobs
Die Skiller nicht
Die Skiller brauchen keinen Luck
Es covert halt auch keiner, ne?
Ich habe es probiert
Hat aber nicht funktioniert
Das kriegen wir nicht mehr
Ja, sag gleich, Leute, ich habe
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Nice
Ich habe gar keinen Bock wirklich
Zu arbeiten bei euch
Ich will einfach nur Geld
Sei ehrlich
Nee, Quatsch
Ihr interessiert mich nicht
Geht mir am Arsch vorbei
Ich brauche halt Geld
Ehrlich gesagt
Das wäre halt so die ehrliche Antwort
Auf viele Fragen in so einem Vorstellungsgespräch
So nach dem Motto
Warum wollen sie unbedingt diesen Job haben?
Und warum sind wir so der geilste Arbeitgeber?
Muss sagen, ja gut
Aber ich brauche Geld
Das wäre halt nur ehrlich, ne?
Ha, was ist mit dem Typ los?
Lol
Boris
Ich versuche mal
Die Fuske
Machste nix
Da machste nix, Leute
Also, Alter
Was für
Alter, mein Team ist
Also normalerweise mecker ich ja nicht
Über mein Team in Battlefield
Aber
What the fuck?
Was ist mit euch verkehrt, ey?
Was ist mit euch verkehrt?
Guckt euch das mal an
Alter
Teamge, please
Stehen wir hier sonst wo rum?
Okay
Eine äußerst geballernste Runde bis jetzt
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung
Ob das der Gegner war
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Alles GG
What?
Wie die immer wissen, dass ich da bin?
Du kannst hier nicht den Kopf rausstrecken
Du bist instant dead
Heck, W46
Der hat sie schon
Wie viele Gegner
Guckt euch das mal an
Und niemand von meinem Team ist da
Niemand
Alle weg
Und die fucking Assault Rifles
Nix mehr
Okay, das können wir schaffen
Das geht
Die letzte Base
Wenn man es gescheit macht
Die ist halbwegs gut zu verteidigen
Das geht
Also, das geht
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir es hinbekommen
Okay, keine Chance
Vielleicht soll ich den Silencer runter machen
Ich mach den Silencer runter
Nice, hat gut funktioniert, Game
Sehr gut, Dankeschön
Dass es so gut funktioniert
Ich wollte nämlich eigentlich hier rein
Was zum?
Alter, dieses Game
Das ist so verbagter Scheiße teilweise
Was ist das für ein Kack?
Alter, warum funktioniert dieses Dreck-Gadget nicht?
Geht doch, ja
Nice
Jetzt funktioniert es
Es wäre gut, wenn es immer funktioniert
Nice, sehr gut
Das ist C++
Du wirst lachen
Das ist wirklich C++
Kein Spaß
Frostbite besteht aus C++
Und .NET, C-Sharp
Für die Level-Build-Tools
Ich kann nicht mehr spielen gerade
Ich halte es immer aus
Leute, das war ein Headshot mit der Shotgun
Habt ihr es gerade gesehen?
Das war wieder ein fucking Headshot mit der Shotgun
Juckt nicht
Nice, und jetzt werde ich one-shotted
Okay, passt mal auf
Ich zeige euch jetzt den geilsten Battlefield-Trick
Mein Leaf, das Game
Damit man sich nicht 30 Sekunden Outro angucken muss
Ja, ich brauche eine Runde Energy-Drink
Dass ich mich wieder halbwegs konzentrieren kann
Ist nicht quasi jedes Game, was nicht auf Unity läuft, ein C++ geschrieben
Vieles, ja
Liegt aber auch einfach daran, weil Unreal in C++ ist
Aber du musst ja, wenn du mit Unreal arbeitest, nicht zwangsläufig
Also je nachdem, wie tief du da einsteigen willst
Also ich bin kein...
Nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich hätte große Ahnung, was Game-Entwicklung angeht
Aber du musst nicht unbedingt selbst C++ programmieren, wenn du Unreal verwendest
Also du kannst ja sehr viel mit Skripts im Editor schon machen
Und ich glaube, für Unreal gibt es hier möglich...
Also du kannst diesen Blueprint-Editor benutzen
Der ist komplett...
Grafisch, soweit ich weiß
Du kannst aber, glaube ich, auch mit...
C-Sharp mittlerweile und Javascript
Sachen interaktiv im Editor skripten
Soweit ich weiß
Wie gesagt, ich habe von Spiele-Entwicklung nicht wirklich viel Plan
Wir sollten...
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wo...
Fuck
Ah, nicht richtig getroffen
Hätte ich ihn mit der Shotgun erwischt, wäre er dead gewesen
Einfach nur...
Dead
Ja, also so viel zum Thema
Ist alles in C++
Vieles ist halt durch Unreal in C++
Und auch historisch ist C++ so eine Sprache
Die ziemlich verbreitet ist in der Game-Entwicklung
Obwohl niemand C++ mag
Das ist ja das Witzige daran
Niemand programmiert gerne in C++
Alle benutzen C++ nur dort, wo es keine gescheiten Alternativen gibt
Du magst C++, das glaube ich dir nicht
Es gibt niemanden, der C++ mag
Außer zum Memen irgendwie
Alter, wie viele Gegner
C++ 17 ist vollkommen okay
Das Problem an C++ 17...
Ach nee, nicht direkt an 17
Okay, dead, nice
...ist, dass die Sprache die letzten Jahre über...
...total inkonsistent und undurchsichtig erweitert wurde
Und du den ganzen Legacy-Kram immer noch drin hast
Was dazu führt, dass es eigentlich keiner mehr wirklich versteht
Gibt auch viele Beispiele zum Thema C++-Sakt
Aber da will ich jetzt nicht mit anfangen
Da quäle ich euch schon oft genug mit
Blöde Idee, hier runter zu gehen
Game?
Das Ding da rumgehüpft
Man kann nicht oft genug über C++ reden
C++ sagt halt einfach komplett
Das ist ja noch nicht mal gebated
So wie wenn ich mich immer über Java lustig mache und sowas
Das ist ja zu...
Sag mal zur Hälfte mal schon gebated
Aber bei C++ meine ich das ernst
Und das ist halt einfach auch so
Oh fuck, nice, Nate
Das Granat des Jahrhunderts war das hier
Okay, ich bin mir unschlüssig, wo ich hin soll gerade
Vielleicht da hoch?
Weil da gerade Dedke Gegner ist
Dedke Teammate
Keine Legehände am Start
Vielleicht kriege ich den Gerät
Ich habe übrigens seit zwei Minuten keinen Gegner mehr gesehen
Nice, sehr gut, Game
Hat er mich stickt?
Hat er mich stickt gerade?
Leute, ich liege in 50 Teammates drin
Oh, da ist sogar ein Medic
Guck mal, da ist sogar ein Medic noch
Also Teammates brauchen wir, das ist geil
Ich pushe jetzt vor...
Wir können nicht weiter pushen
Ich kann nur...
Jaja, ist gut, Game
Ich gehe wieder zurück
Ich mache mal auf Aushilfs-Medic
Ich mache ein bisschen was auf Aushilfs-Medic
Boris
Sag mal, es gibt keine Gegner, ne?
Die Gegner sind quasi gleich dead
Keine Gegner, das gibt es nicht
Outdated, overrated, debated
Alter, so schlecht
Ist die Dynamik in den Games immer so komisch?
Ganz ehrlich, die Runde ist merkwürdig
Die Runde ist echt merkwürdig
Hört mal auf zu kombatieren
Okay, nice
Pass auf, wir verlieren jetzt auch gleich A noch
Ne?
19 Tickets
Also die Runde habe ich kaum Gegner gesehen
Oh, shit
Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen
Gehen wir mal hier durch
Dachte ich mir
Pass auf, diffuse, ge?
Auf, gib ihm
Sehr schön
Sind die wieder da oben?
Ich habe gerade da oben jemanden sterben sehen
Okay, nice, win
Nichts gesehen an Gegner in die Runde
Nichts gemacht, aber easy win an der zweiten Base
Alles klar
Was ist eigentlich aus
Reverse Runden geworden in Rush?
Also früher war es in Rush so, dass du immer eine Runde hin, eine Runde zurück gespielt hast
Sodass du mehr oder weniger garantiert hattest
Attacker und Defender abwechselnd
Was ist daraus geworden?
Das war Legacy oder wie?
Klingt ja eigentlich nach einer sinnvollen Sache
Oder was denkt ihr?
Klingt doch sinnvoll, oder?
50% Angreifer, 50% Attacker
Danke für den Sub, Gift
Klingt doch eigentlich sinnvoll
Einmal Hinrunde, einmal Rückrunde
Aber das war zu offensichtlich und zu naheliegend
Sowas zu machen
Wisst ihr was auch geil ist?
Bad Company 3 wird es ja nicht geben
Weil DICE ja selbst sagt, sie wissen nicht mehr
Was ein Bad Company überhaupt zu einem guten Game gemacht hat
Und ich denke mir, Leute, ich rufe mich halt an
Ja, ernsthaft, das haben die im Interview gesagt
Mal vor paar Jahren, ist schon ein bisschen her
Aber du kannst suchen danach
Ja, das haben die gesagt
Aber wie gesagt, die können einfach Fans fragen
Oder ich hätte da mal einen Vorschlag an DICE
Ich könnte das Game einfach selbst intern mal ein bisschen spielen
Und dann
Euch mal ganz agil zusammenhocken und überlegen
Was hat denn das Game ausgezeichnet?
Was hat das Game gut gemacht?
Ich weiß, es ist ziemlich heftig zu verlangen
Von Spieleentwicklern, dass sie ihr eigenes bzw. Games spielen
Kann man ja 2023 nicht machen
Aber es wäre mal was
Das Games spielen
Beziehungsweise zumindest mal
Vielleicht sich das anzugucken, was Leute dazu sagen
Warum sie es gut fanden
Ich meine, wenn man sich überlegt
Das, ähm
Es gab mal einen lustigen Artikel darüber
Als id Software Quake
Programmiert hat
Oder Quake, nee nicht Quake
Doom, glaub, könnte auch Quake gewesen sein
Nee, ich glaub es war Quake
Entwickelt hat
Da hat einer der Entwickler
Ein, ähm
So einen Arbeitsplatz gehabt
Das er auf dem Klo weiterprogrammieren konnte
Weil er hat gesagt
Es, es nervt ihn
Dass er aufs Klo gehen muss und aufhören
Und aufhören muss, nee
Er hat gesagt, es nervt ihn, dass wenn er halt aufs Klo muss
Dass er aufhören muss zu programmieren
Und dann hat er sich das irgendwie so gebaut, dass er einfach
Einfach ins, aufs Klo gehen konnte und weiterprogrammieren
Eigentlich auch, nice, nice Idee, oder?
Sowas brauch ich auch
Ist er auf dem
Ich wollte meinen Kopf noch einziehen
Fuck, Alter
Die sind aber auch hart wieder
Nice
Okay, B
B, vielleicht können wir von hier oben was machen
Nein
Reds, Reds, Leute, ich lieg mitten in euch
Ich lieg mitten in euch
Jawohl, jawohl, lege Hände
In Battlefield es sind einfach immer die, die man nicht sieht, ne
Der, der hat ordentlich gefressen eben der Typ
Kopf raus, bam, Kopf weg
ESL, ja
Ich sag jetzt, Reverse ESL Finals
Der ist bestimmt noch da hier
Ne, ist er nicht
Au, au, au, au
Okay, okay
Shit, Alter, shit, ge
Nice
Huge play, Leute, massive play
Ich glaub, die machen Diffuse-Gear, oder?
Game
Ne, gar kein Diffuse-Gear
Not, not Diffuse
Shit, ich wollt eigentlich da hoch
Vielleicht krieg ich nen Reds, ich lieg mittendrin
Also, wenn wir Glück haben
Meine Teammates sind jetzt erst da
Ah, jetzt, rein, rein hier
Spawn
Next
Oh, shit
Okay, 10, 9, 8
Ah, oh Gott, jetzt gehen wir rein
Hab ich nicht gesehen
Hab ich nicht gesehen, den Typ
Blindge
Au
Alter, das Game fuckt mich so ab
Es fuckt mich so ab, dass der Grappling-Hook nicht funktioniert, wenn er funktionieren sollte
So ätzend
Oh
Das wär schön mit der Shotgun ins
Ins Gehirn direkt, äh
Nice
Da kommt bestimmt gleich noch was von hinten
Reds, please, dankeschön, nice
Wow
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho
Da habt ihr nicht mit gerechnet, hä?
Oh
Ah doch, jetzt geht's
Dass jetzt der Woblos um die Ecke gestellt kommt
Okay
Unschlüssig, wo?
Aber wir können mal ins Spawn gucken
Hier hinten
Nice, der ist dead
Nice
Dead
Nicht zu spammen mit den ARs
Ich klick eigentlich zwischendurch immer
Aber das resetet nicht richtig
Au
Okay, jetzt mal ernsthaft
Wie hat der Typ mich durch die Wand
Mit der, mit ner UMP gegriffen?
Mit der, mit ner UMP gekillt?
Ist da mein Arm rausgeklitscht oder sowas?
Und die Hitbox durch und
Konnte mich killen?
Hex, muss
Hexor-Kram
Schneiber
Oh, wie ich nicht mehr, wie ich nicht mehr zielen kann gerade
Ich kann mich nicht mehr konzentrieren, Leute
Es ist zu viel
Zu viel für mein Boomer-Hirn
Boah
Anstrengende Sache
Okay, mal gucken, was die nächste Runde ist
Vielleicht spielen wir noch ne Runde
Outstanding Performance
Muss mal gucken, wieviel FPS ich kriege
Wenn ich nicht am streamen bin
Noch gar nicht ausprobiert
Ich mein, nicht, dass 340, 300 FPS irgendwie unplayable wären
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich vielleicht endlich mal die
Keg W46 am Start?
Battle Pass Nummer?
Oh ne
Alter, wie oft muss ich noch spielen, bis ich Battle Pass 27 hab?
Ich geb da kein Geld für aus, Leute
Das können die vergessen
Kein Cent
Gibt's da mehr von mir
Auch niemand
Der Champion-Muzzlebreaker
Wollen wir wetten?
Hourglass?
Caspian Border ist halt in
2042 jetzt auch nicht so der Hit
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich fand's in Battlefield 3 schon
Also es ist
Es war in Battlefield 3 schon nicht eines meiner
Meiner Favorites
Was soll mir das eigentlich sagen?
Time to get the fuck into Dodge
Was soll das bedeuten, Leute?
Was möchte er uns sagen?
Time to get the fuck into Dodge
Was soll das heißen?
Versteh ich nicht
In Deutsch heißt der so viel wie ausweichen
Der Sheriff gewinnt?
Dass du in Dogecoin investieren sollst
Ja, genau, das glaub ich
Bestimmt, bestimmt wird es das sein, ja
Es geht um Dodge City aus den Western
Heinze, ich
Okay
Den Zusammenhang hätt ich mir jetzt nicht erschlossen
Das hätt ich nicht kapiert
Ich geh mal an B rüber
Heinze
Okay, nächstes
Ich komm nicht lebend an, Leute
Im Leben komm ich hier nicht lebend an
Wow
Es war klar
Ich hab's mal probiert
Ich hab mir gedacht, ey, schieß mal nicht
Lauf
Oh nee, ich hab wieder so ein PP-Guard-Team, was sonst wo sitzt
Geh nicer, Dude
Okay, Hardcore PP-Guard-Team
Die kommen keine 5 Meter vorwärts
Ich würd sagen, time to get the fuck into Dodge
Das ist doch immer das Bedeutende
Ich kann mir nur nicht vorstellen, dass das was mit dem Western zu tun hat
Verwirrungstaktik, Leute
Ich bin, ja, ich auch
Combat, Combat, Combat
Oh, ganz schlechte Idee
Nice
Okay, erstmal ein bisschen rumgesprayt
Ich checke nicht von wo, aber okay
Jump mal
Alter
Die kommen wieder nicht vorwärts
Okay, Five-Head-Play
Wir brauchen ein richtig massive Six-Head-Play, dass es weitergeht
Hoffentlich kann ich hier reinspawnen bei dem
Ah, fuck it, Alter
Was ist das wieder für ne
Okay, nice, die sind besser
Wir müssen irgendwie vor
Shit, shit, shit, shit
Nice
Oh, der Pants-Man, der Pants-Man
Oh, zwei Panzers
Okay, pass auf
Das ist hier
Das ist das Six-Head-Play, was wir brauchen
Passt
Passt, close
Close call
Close, close
Es war noch nicht auf Six-Head-Level
Es war noch nicht ganz auf Six-Head-Niveau
Not Six-Head
Aber jetzt gleich Six-Head
Shit
Vielleicht haben wir aber B
Es wird knapp
A, äh, A mein ich
Was?
Fuckin' shit
Kannste ja mal probieren
Das ist wieder so
Komplett passives Team, was nicht nach vorne pusht
Wir haben auch keinen Heli-Flieger, der irgendwie mobiler Spawn-Punkt ist oder sowas
Ey, Leute, noch ne gescheite Runde
Noch eine gescheite Runde
Gescheite Map
Boah, was geht
Da mach ich Schluss für heute
Es gibt nen Urban Dictionary-Eintrag dafür, was der Typ sagt
Okay, da müssen wir gleich gucken
Okay, lass mal erklären
Also
Is a reference to Dodge City, Kansas, which was the first
Äh, okay
Western-Reference
Ja gut, das passt ja auch
Es gab ja auch diesen Cowboy-Skin
Für, für McKay
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es den noch gab
Das ist das, wo die Leute schon gesagt haben
Im Feedback direkt
Dass der, der Cowboy-Skin
Und der
Was war das, der Weihnachtsmann-Skin für Boris
Keine gute Idee ist und was haben sie gemacht
Hat er einfach trotzdem reingepatcht
Ins, gescheite Map, okay
Ah, Defend
Äh, Defend?
Ah, Destroy
Sollte man vor allem mal richtig lesen
Äh
Pepega stellt's
Nix wie weg, nix wie weg
Lege Hände
Und Rats
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Okay, die sind blind
Die sind, die sind, die sind
Die sind blind, die Gegner einfach
Hoffentlich ist mein Team nicht auch blind
Ah, die sind alle dead
Okay, das geht natürlich auch
Disabled
Shit, shit, shit
Shit, ge
Shit
Der Typ da oben
Ich hätte eigentlich wissen müssen, dass er da oben ist
Ich hab ihn nicht gesehen
Der Typ da oben
Ich hätte eigentlich wissen müssen, dass er da ist
Der hat die ganze Zeit schon da oben geschimmelt
Vielleicht, vielleicht können wir wirklich hier nochmal
Arsch
Leute, meine Augen sind zu schlecht
Ich, ich seh die Gegner nicht mehr
Es hätte klappen können
So, so geht, so geht's halt dem Objective Player, ne
Ich bin ja froh, dass die anderen noch krasser sucken als ich
Okay, machen wir, machen wir das Ganze nochmal jetzt
Zack, da, so
Ey, what the fuck
Die sehen einen instant
Vielleicht sollten wir das doch anders machen
Ich sollte doch nicht alleine vorpushen
Okay, wir haben B gelegt
Dann ist jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt rüber zu gehen auf A
Ach nee, A ist schon weg, okay
Ich hab nix gesagt
Ich seh schon gleich einen von hinten hier anrücken
Da ist doch einer
Wusste ich doch, dass hier einer ist
So, und jetzt ein bisschen von der Seite hier rein stelzen
Alter, warum pusht da keiner, man?
Fuck it
Was ist das hier schon wieder gewesen?
0-6, geiler Dude
Nee, nee, nee, nee
So können wir nicht aufhören
Da muss schon ne gescheite Runde nochmal bei rumkommen
Ich mein, ich hab alles probiert
Ich hab gelegt zweimal
Ich hab versucht zu flanken
Zu flanken, zu flanken
Ich könnte, also ich wüsste nicht, was ich mehr machen soll
Next
Vielleicht nochmal Valparaiso
Ja, behaupte ich auch mal
Vielleicht nochmal ne Runde Valparaiso
So ne ordentliche, ordentliche Rushmap
Oh Gott
Wenn wir Attacker sind, probiere ich es nochmal auf die erste Base
Ansonsten gehe ich raus und such nochmal neu
Heute ist Tag von Caspian Border, ne?
Okay, wir sind Amis
No solo shit
Eins, zwei, drei, vier
Ich fahr mal mit
Ich hoffe, der fährt in die Base
Und fährt nicht direkt in den nächsten Panzerschuss
Und fährt auch nicht an den Rand der Map, um zu snipen
Also ist immer gefährlich, mit Leuten mitzufahren
Pass auf, wir sind dead, wir sind dead
Ha, ich wusste es
Alter, der ist auf den Panzer direkt straight zugefahren
Was ist mit euch verkehrt, Alter?
Beste Verwirrung, Strats
Lege Henne
Okay, YOLO, YOLO
Shit
Kannste ja mal probieren
Aber wir sind schon mal zumindest ein bisschen mehr in der Base, als die letzten Male
Zu viel, zu viel, zu viel
Nice, nice, hier rein schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell
Fuck, jetzt ist wieder alles weg
Okay, wir haben ein Jet, was im Endeffekt schon heißt, wir haben eigentlich verloren, weil wir kein Spawn-Heli haben können
Äh, haben wir Glück?
Ist in dem Squad was frei?
Von den Typen mit dem Spawn-Beacon?
Ne
Aber
Äh, wie, Alter
Wie wärs mit fahren, Mann?
Okay, wie kommen wir da hin?
Mach mal kurz ne Runde Silencer drauf
Mein Silencer war noch nicht aufgeschraubt
Ich konnte grad nicht schießen, wo ich fünf Gegner vor mir hatte
Hat ziemlich gesackt
Shit
Ah, fuck
Krieg ich ne RETZ? Haben wir was?
Ne, haben wir nicht
Hm
Nice, nice, nice, nice
Guter Spawn
Oh, fast
PP Guard
Jawoll
Oh
Ach, das war die Granate
Ich hab schon gedacht, Alter, wie hat der mich denn
Weggesprayt
Hat der aber gar nicht
Was ist hier los?
Alter, what the
Fuck
Yep, cock
Was ist hier los?
Nice, okay
Das war wieder fürs Boomer-Hirn zu viel
Ich hab nix gecheckt
Ich bin einfach
Ich bin einfach nur rumgerannt im Kreis
Und hab alles hip-fired
Was irgendwie in der Nähe war
Seht ihr, wie sich das nicht resetet?
Okay, weiter geht's
So, diesmal gibt's easy win, Leute
Eats win
Woah
War das die Desert Eagle?
Mit was hat er mich gekillt?
Ne, G57
Es hat sich nämlich angefühlt
wie einfach nur ein Treffer
Headshot so
Oder zwei Treffer
Aber es war eigentlich
Es war ne G57
Ja
Guckt's euch an
Ich warte mal, bis unser Heli-Typ
vielleicht losfliegt
Meint ihr, der fliegt los?
Und meint ihr, der kann fliegen
vor allem?
Nein
Geiler Typ
Da war was
Ich hab direkt
Ich hab direkt n Gegner gesehen
Hier direkt an B
Oh
Yep
Yep, Tank
Dead
Ich wollte noch weg
Ich hab mir gedacht
Scheiße, der guckt in meine Richtung
Die defusen gleich
Ne, waren sie nicht?
Okay
Ich hab ein bisschen
meine Bedenken
an B ranzugehen
Zu viele Tanks
Okay, wir müssen an B ran
Wow
Okay, wir haben's
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht
Zu viel, zu viel los
Nice Game
GG
Wow
MonkaS
Alter
Lass das Haus stehen
Kann ich jetzt raus?
Darf ich meinen Kopf raus machen?
Vielleicht?
Trau mich nicht raus, Leute
Okay, nice
Jetzt ist der Tank kaputt
Jetzt trau ich mich raus
Close
Gut, dass der noch mehr PP geaimt hat als ich
Okay, jetzt sollten wir doch eigentlich
relativ safe hier rüber kommen
Okay, den hol ich noch
Gachi
Habt ihr's gehört?
Er hat gesagt, Gachi hold on
Lul, evaded
Okay, das ist ne schöne Abschlussrunde, glaub ich
Da geht ganz gut was
Waren die Wege hier auch so lang auf der originalen Karte?
Oder haben die das noch verlängert?
Ich mein, das war auch schon immer lang, aber
Aber doch nicht so lang
By the way, ich teppe, aber das setzt sich nicht richtig zurück
Okay, Chat
Zählte das als Abschlussrunde oder muss ich noch eine spielen?
Ne
Oh man
Warum gebannt?
Ich bin nicht gebannt
Der Server ist gecrashed
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
Das mit dem Bann haben nur irgendwelche Cheatbait-Leute im Chat geschrieben
Das sind offiziell
Valparaiso
Nice, nochmal ne gescheite Map zum Schluss
Wahrscheinlich jetzt Defense und wir werden vernichtet
Rush
Defense sind wir
Oder sind die Russen Attacker auf Valparaiso?
Aber ich glaube, Russen sind immer Defender
Ne, brauchen keinen Silencer
Gucken wir mal
Er springt runter, springt runter, damit er sich bashen kann
Okay
Wir müssen, okay, ich muss
Das funktioniert so nicht
By the way
By the way, der Spawn ist falsch
Warum ist der Spawn
Warum ist denn der Spawn da?
Das ist falsch
Der Spawn ist normalerweise hier
An der ersten Base
Hatten die keinen Bock, den Spawn zu platzieren?
Das ist ja mal mega für den Arsch
Was ein Scheiß, Alter
Noch nicht mal ihre eigenen Maps kriegen sie richtig recycelt
In Ass geschootet
Aber richtig Gachi-Bass-Style war das gerade
Hyper-Gachi
Okay, Moment, hab ich den auch erwischt?
Ich dachte, mit der Shotgun kann man da eigentlich nicht viel schief...
...nicht viel falsch machen, aber anscheinend doch
Ist der gelandet?
Ja
Blut
Wow
An enemy
Sind die dead?
Was? Ein PP-Geheim, aber es funzt gerade
Neuling 234, heißt der so?
Ich hätte wetten können, da ist einer
Da ist einer
Ne, anscheinend nicht, okay
Ich hab nichts gesagt
Noch ein Panzer
Oh shit, wo ist der Heli?
Pass auf, pass auf, pass auf
Ich wollte gerade, da springt doch gleich einer runter
Aber kann keiner mehr runter springen
Wow
Alter, direkt vor der Nase
Der Panzer
Nice
Okay
Das war ne gute letzte Runde
Wie auch immer, der andere Typ 20 Kills gemacht hat
Aber ist okay, ich will mich mal nicht beschweren
Dass man ein bisschen gecarried wird
Ist schon okay
War aber auch ein gutes Squad hier, guckt mal
Hufnagelpisti
Alles klar, die haben teilweise Namen
Neuling 234
Ich würde sagen, mit 1 zu 6 trifft das wohl auch zu, ja
Ich würde ja interessieren, was er gespielt hat
Kann man die Leute observen?
Ne, das wäre ja viel zu toxic, wenn man sich Profile angucken könnte von den Leuten
Das geht natürlich nicht
Das muss man vermeiden
Das ist nicht möglich
Das wäre ja, das wäre ultra toxic
Wenn man sich die Profile angucken könnte und dann sagen würde
Oh, der scheint ja noch neu in dem Game zu sein
Ultra toxic, Legacy Feature, muss sofort weg
Sowas aber auch, ne, ne, ne, ne
Manchmal, manchmal würde ich es mir halt gerne angucken
Oh, ich wollte eigentlich aufhören
Was ist es? Attacker, Defender? Ne
Ne, ne, Schluss für heute Leute
Wir sehen uns, es war anstrengend
Ne, es war anstrengend
Aber ich hoffe es trotzdem gefallen, schön dass so viele da gewesen sind
Obwohl ich zu einer für die meisten ziemlich unmöglichen Zeit angefangen habe zu streamen
Wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut, see you